[Music]
hi everyone
when's the last time we recorded a
podcast
well i do not remember it's been a hot
minute uh
mommy's home mommy's back good for you
is back in production
uh my health is um
wavering slowly slowly i'm triumphing
uh over my health issues and um i'm back
and i think the first thing we can maybe
do
is a balanced beam of health concern i
feel like we just need to address
uh all the litany of elephants in the
living room of everyone that thinks i'm
an abusive relationship
and falling on fake beams uh we're just
following on
we need to have a press conference
addressing uh my instagram over the last
uh 30 days because people are worried
people are scared
they are uh what's the feedback what's
the feedback um there's a lot of
um who hit whitney does whitney need
help
please help whitney for the love of god
help whitney
honestly it would be so much less
embarrassing if someone was hitting me
at this point i've just been riding back
she's actually doing treppies work
but the other thing i keep getting is
like did she get a nose job did she
because i busted my nose open on a table
i'll tell you the story in a minute who
who busts their nose open at a nose job
then goes and then takes a picture of it
okay what nose job starts with the cut
right here
[Laughter]
i know that's just people wanting so bad
to be like she has plastic surgery by
the way you guys just so you know
when i if i get a nose job i'll tell you
i'm gonna do no cause she won't have a
nose left look how small her nose is
already
she'll be voldemort that's how you know
she's gonna know this job but by the way
you'll come with me
i'll be doing stories i'll get a nose
shot i'll be tagging hashtag ad
everyone will have nose jobs garth
fisher like trust me i'm not gonna hide
any plastic surgeries from you guys i'm
pretty open about that kind of shit you
know what i mean
it's like two days after i was blasting
on instagram my ass like jiggling on a
machine like i don't have secrets from
you guys
i just love the idea to a fault i'm too
honest the idea of people thinking that
you sat up real quick like i got a quick
picture
and just snapped a real quick shot of
the doctor's first incision
it it is a sketchy story though because
i
thought in my lunesta nyquil uh
covet haze which we'll talk about uh
when annie letterman is here
um about i did have kovid um
and i thought i walked into a beam which
is a real beam yeah no that sounds even
as i say it sounds like a lie
it does sound like a lie but there is in
the uh in the home
the rental home yeah in the rental home
there are two just
random beams that jut from the wall
right by the door to the kitchen yeah
it makes no sense i've hit my head on
them many times
so there are just random beams and then
huh but what actually happened is even
more embarrassing
which is that in the middle of the night
i was so cold
and i bent over to try to plug in a
heater and slammed the side table is a
coffee table
the side table is this is a big marvel
thing it's a giant marble table
and i just slam my face in it um and uh
went back to sleep actually and then
like two hours later woke up in like a
pool of blood
and had to go get my nose stitched up it
doesn't look i feel like it's gonna heal
okay yeah it's gonna heal great yeah but
then i went to the um
uh dr lancer and he just set my face on
fire so that it will all heal
matches to you yeah it made it it just
looked so much worse after that i mean
the strangest part is the um
is the amount of injuries you got in a
small amount of time yeah it was wild
i mean to from from the sickness to the
to the uti
to the busted nose to the big hand all
of them were related all of them because
it was my
my guard was down like there was a dog i
had a foster uh
a foster that tried to attack my dog
frank and normally when i'm thinking
clearly and not uncovered and
like functional you put your finger in
the butthole
yes you put a finger in the butthole
wasn't thinking clearly was too foggy
uh the dog went out my dog frank and i
just put my hand
right in its mouth and now my finger
looks like a ginger root right and i got
a splinter
you did get a sweater i did look guys i
fully
like had coconuts my face is bleeding
and ben's like i have a splinter
we need to take it it was a big splinter
it was what was it from this table
that's right
which is going to be pretty rough she's
going to go soon the splinter the table
the table
oh um so what else were people worried
about what else do we need to address
people were mainly worried about why you
kept posting uh bloody selfies
it was it was a very toasty it was a
very black market
dark web situation people are like
people go to you for
laughs and fun and you were like what if
i was bleeding she's dating army hammer
now people are very confused he's in the
corner just lapping up blood from a dog
bowl
so should i take that down it's already
happened
i know but i mean people were sending us
messages like can you please
put like a warning up really and i was
like no this is saul
oh come on it's all part four y'all are
soft who cares it's a bloody nose you
never seen a bloody nose before
yeah it's a bloody nose a bit off ear
ripped apart hand
my femur what you ever seen my femur
before
you've never seen my organs i'm rose
budding i don't know i maybe i'm over
sharing i just feel like now i feel like
the horse has left the barn in terms of
over sharing with fans at this point
maybe it's just too much is it too much
i think seeing your innards is a lot
then you guys need to reel me in maybe
someone else needs to run my social
media
is it too much it's over now it's
already happening
i know but 20 20 21 do you plan on
posting more bloody photos i don't know
i guess not you guys couldn't handle it
you guys can handle a little blood how
many
fans i don't know watching mma fights
and you can't watch one bloody nose on
my feed
well you don't want to see someone you
love be bloodied i just want to know
what you thought was going to happen
you're i'm going to post myself drenched
in blood and then what was the reaction
you were going to get i don't know they
were going to be like
she is crazy she just wanted to she's so
silly
i just wanted to share what's going on
because i hadn't posted on instagram
stories for like
four days and people were like are you
okay she must be really sick she's not
posting stories
so i just want to let them know i'm not
ignoring you i truly had like a
are you okay
no one can hear you see you benton oh
i'm acting out bleeding
my new thing
yeah benton only does this for the
viewers not the listeners
listen well pretend he's fully miming
he's fully understanding
and you would enjoy it if you go to
youtube benton has no respect for our
listeners he only wants to fuck with our
youtube people
benton refuses it is a blessing to be
able to see
benton says i have a face for youtube
you have multiple senses
i'm doing the audio podcast he's doing
the video podcast either way we're
doing different shows what did you think
was gonna happen i just was sharing
i don't know i didn't think people would
get like so upset i don't know
i think you just made him sad i'm sorry
i'm sorry you're right i owe you an
apology it was out of line
i'm the i will own the mistake do i
archive it should i take it down
i don't know all those masks we made of
your bloody face how we're gonna sell
those now
yeah maybe that was i went too far
that's kind of my brand though
i'm intense you're in or you're out you
fuck with me or you don't
how about that you just became like a
medical journal instagram it's
just different surgeries i know but yeah
my hand is healing
it was touch and go there for a second
you get stitches i know i got eight
stitches on this finger it was not great
um and but that's kind of par for the
course for me i
don't i don't mind a couple scars here
and there you know
okay rambo okay um anything else i need
to address
well i mean you did go you were in and
out of the hospital
yes for a while there yes yes yes
because i couldn't keep food down
uh so i was having to get like fluids
and stuff yeah i made friends with a lot
of nurses
it was wild we were gonna go somewhere
in christmas together and then we got
tested on the 24th
and i just i mean i just thought i was
like getting old
like my my bones were hurting my muscles
were hurting
i was like i just was like that's my
body now
like just getting older 38 years old and
then i actually felt a little bit
relieved when he was like you have cove
but i was like oh thank god i thought i
was just getting old like there was a
little bit of a relief
in the diagnosis oh okay as sick as that
is
it's a creepy virus dude it's a creepy
virus emily emily
uh just so you guys know new year new
system we have emily
noonan my former assistant from five
years ago
uh yeah who is now running the podcast
making sure we are
on time shooting opens delivering to you
guys
being more organized there she is
emily and i uh uh and i met
five years ago i was interviewing for an
assistant no we met seven years ago
oh but i've worked for you for three
years right okay this math is fuzzy
very fuzzy i have an excuse i had
coverage that's why what's your excuse
i'm not the numbers person so emily is
uh truly the funniest person i know
uh i hired her because benton did you
hear that i've heard it before
it's just whoever's in the room it'll
change
we're both kids though we're the
funniest person we're both in the room
right now
i'm sorry that i like to throw out
accolades
i enjoy it uh uh i hired emily not only
because she was
obviously wildly qualified but in the
interview she told me that
she ate peanut butter for a week to gain
weight for her sister's wedding so that
her sister
looked thinner in the photos yeah just
it was just a really altruistic thing to
do yeah and i was like this bitch takes
one for the team and you're hired
thank you she said here we are
everything for me yeah
what did did your sister know you were
doing that no but um
she really appreciated afterwards she
did the lemonade uh
juice cleanse like the cayenne pepper
juice cleanse and i ate jars of peanut
butter
all day all day and drink coca-cola we
got to get those photos queued up
oh at some point my arms are like it was
the kindest thing i ever did i actually
still haven't lost the weight
they said how nice of emily to have her
arms replaced with hams
um so we have emily running a very tight
ship how's the experience been so far
it's been great yeah you know yeah i
love you i love you
yeah i'm glad i'm happy to be with you
again we're gonna
it's so weird isn't it no not really
also i've decided that um this is my way
of not getting canceled i'm just hiring
all the people that could cancel me
that have worked for me in the past that
know where all the bodies are buried
whitney heard i was writing of shopping
a book around yeah like would you like
to come and work on my show
sign this nda i still haven't signed one
yet shit
here's some money so i'm just gonna hire
all the people uh that
would possibly snitch on me wild and
then we can start a union
we shouldn't we'll talk uh we have
another new hire
on the podcast grace is here now say hi
grace
hi happy to be here so benton got a
promotion tell us about it
i did i am now a full-time water
aerobics instructor at the north dell
senior living home
so that's really fun guys benton is no
longer my nebulous
kind of assistant kind of podcast host
kind of
dad kind of mom uh slash caretaker
yeah not anymore now i am you're going
to see me here
and you're going to see me on the good
for you page on the instagram page which
you guys should follow
me and emily there the good for you
instagram page is about to start
popping off with serious content they're
gonna run it
uh you'll see us on youtube um lots of
new
you'll see us in a much more creative
way yeah now that we have
grace who is a genius who can actually
you know read and write
[Laughter]
so that will be really helpful i think
for everyone
and it will free up my time yeah i will
and it'll free up my time to do my water
aerobics
ben and i hired you because after the um
after we shot the special
you were like i can be your assistant
and i was like yeah you can like it was
just
you know i thought like i mean it seemed
easy yeah
i think i mean i was watching everybody
else's assistant so they're not doing
anything and then
and they weren't and they still don't
probably
yeah and then i was like where's wait a
minute something's wrong
this is a lot and there's like you have
to use that numbers and time people's
name there's so many names to remember
like get get greg oldsdale and i'm like
i don't know that he is
like where would i find it but i love
that you wouldn't bother to find out you
just wouldn't do it
no i would i would know there were
things like he's busy i know like he
literally
instead of going like who is this person
or like let me call a former assistant
he just would be like i couldn't figure
out who that was
i was like okay well if you want to talk
to him that badge will do it yourself
it was just like and like i mean we were
getting calls to my agents
like hey we need to be able to get in
touch with you like i've been getting
talking to's for my
i don't i didn't realize how much stuff
was falling through the cracks my mantra
is nothing isn't possible and benton's
was if you want something done right you
got to do yourself
that's true i was like listen you've
worked hard your whole life don't stop
now
thank you benton benton refused to
infantilize me you made me stronger
she would just be like she would be like
we need to we need to you know set some
dates for me to do
some some phone calls and and some zoom
meetings and i'd be like what if we
start a company
i don't know what if you do a reality tv
show ben is like photo shoot let's go do
a photo shoot where you're half naked
painting your nose blue i just had
different visions benton's a visionary
you're a visionary you're not a
logistics person
here's the secret guys if you want to do
one job get another job then just prove
you'd be better at the other
that might always been my plan yeah i
was like i don't
want to work at this counter but i'll
pretend i'll be friends with those
people
and i'll get that job over there at the
moment just get a job and then try for a
different one
get a job and be like you know why i'm
not good at this because i'm a better
lawyer you just showed how valuable you
were at other things
and you promoted yourself and if you
didn't like that then i don't tell you
yeah you were like i'm going to pretend
i can do this job to get my foot in the
door
and then i'm going to dazzle her and you
got to keep track of all of it you have
to be like
hey you missed the flight to england i'm
like but look at this merch
you did that made money you did now what
it's it's it's really hard to argue with
yeah you'd be like well
i missed three meetings but this post
143 000 likes
that's that was that's how i work
exactly what you would do i'm like
listen
these are my fault i don't have to love
i want to alanis morissette i would be
loved even when i'm
you know wrong mm-hmm i was just talking
about that we also could not
find someone to replace you yeah we
hired grace because she answered the
phone
[Music]
untrue let's talk about why grace got
the job we talk a lot on the show why we
hire people benton talk about the people
that you interviewed
and how interviewed probably oh let's
say like i did
115 people yeah um give or take and by
interviewed i mean we didn't talk to all
them some of them i just like went
through their resumes and i talked to
maybe like 45 of them wow
um jesus and it was you figured out how
to call them back
yeah well i actually i made them call me
i said can you call me at this time
yeah i did i did i mean i was like we
don't have a zoom can you send one i did
let's chart now
let's see what you got here yeah so i
mean you're hired can you please call us
and then literally the interview
processes i'm like so how do you feel
about emails
can you read i'd be like how do you feel
about calendars
that's really what i would ask and they
would be like i mean that's what i do
and my job now is like
perfect so you want to keep doing it
mm-hmm
but it was just a lot of like the main
thing we ran into is a lot of people
that had like
bigger dreams yeah and they wanted them
right now
yeah like a lot of people were like can
i write with her and i was like
i mean probably not uh
it was just a lot it was a lot it was a
lot of like but i was right so a lot of
people that were like i really want this
job but so i can do something
i would like i understand that but we
can't have more which is what everybody
wants i would like to interject though
because
whitney doesn't want a career assistant
like whitney does like to hire people
that can move on to something else a
hundred percent
it's just real ballsy to you at least
have to do the dance
i know no one wants to be an assistant
forever i know you have other aspects
it's not news to me right it's just real
ballsy to come in day one
yeah can i write with her also at 25
years old you don't want to be running a
show you have no fucking idea what
you're doing
but i learned from someone else when you
do get your opportunity
you're prepared i wanted to make that
point because it's just it's important
for people to know that you're a grower
yeah i would make the point jumper you
can't stop as i have not
let you leave my bosom no for seven
years you've promoted me yeah
you know and now when i try to do
anything assistant you're like don't do
that yeah
when i try to hire i hire someone as an
assistant to be like one day you're
gonna run my company one day you're
gonna run a show one day i would like to
work for you one day right but at least
come in so now emily used to work for me
now i work for emily
but um
she said i've been waiting but please
regain the seat
i will say a lot of people i would say
the one of the main things that i ran
into that
i wouldn't even pass them on to whitney
was if i was like okay so what's your
expectation for this job and
multiple people would be like i would
probably work like four hours and then i
would have the weekends off
i work four hours during the week i
could probably finish everything but
then i was like
what is the weekend where's the grit
where's the where is the moxie i can't
decide if i
respect that though or i'm horrified by
it well they've learned it from
celebrities we've learned it from people
being like
ask for what you're worth you're worth
everything but you're not worth anything
i mean
you're not oh but you're not yet you
have i mean how are you
but you have like all these like
oscar-winning actresses being like you
can do anything and make sure you ask
for what you're worth and then you're
just like well what am i worth i'm just
don't make it up as i go
i don't know it was it the whole thing
was like bone chilling the whole thing
was pretty bone
the the entitlement is really shocking
that's impressive because but it also it
doesn't benefit you do you know what i'm
saying it's like saying i want to be in
a bodybuilding competition well then you
better work out for two years no but it
didn't build the muscle it is confusing
to blame the people that are doing it
though because they're not just making
that up on their own they're learning
that somewhere yeah
they're not just coming out of the womb
like i deserve it all like someone's
telling you that
yeah so where are you learning it from
and yeah the only place i always go back
to them like they have to be learning
from social media yeah
you have to be learning from the
multitude of quotes and videos and
tweets about how everyone is like
special and you are
but not in every job yeah but it's also
but that's not my that's not like i
can't just go
that's not my favorite that's not my
thing my thing is work harder than
anybody
work longer than anybody be better than
everybody as a female comic we all had
to work twice as hard to get half as far
do not show up to a job interview and be
like i'm better than this and you should
be so lucky that's just
it doesn't work yeah i don't subscribe
to that
at all which is a really big reason why
grace got the job because grace just
didn't say anything i would just be like
i would just be like hey grace how do
you thought this and she'd be like cool
the thing i loved the most about grace
is that uh when i first talked to her
uh i don't what did we what did i say i
said something you're like oh you have
to know that i'm unhinged
and i was like sorry but i was really
trying i literally in like i'm at a
point in my life like i just want you to
know
i'm unhinged yeah this isn't going to
change
i like my life is functioning the way
it's functioning
uh and like you either keep up or you
don't i'm not going to pretend like this
isn't a
somewhat chaotic experience or you
interview out right
so you said you like you know that i'm
unhinged right and i was like
with my horrible hearing i was like wait
sorry did you just say you're unhinged
or on hinge and then i
like corrected myself and i said oh no
no you wouldn't be on hinge because
you're engaged and you just went oh i'm
actually not engaged anymore and i was
like
okay and grace literally just went well
that was the worst thing anyone could
have done in a job interview
and you just like called yourself out
which i love like instead of like
pretending that you know
oh no i mean i knew or just you know
what i mean like yeah but i need to know
that you can roll with surprises
and roll with you know yeah what if she
puffed up a cake one day
i said that and then i put her through a
haunted house whitney and maya's
behavior has changed
being around a 24 year old all the time
okay so being around a 24 year old
is been so funny for me because the way
that you're just
innocent questions shame me is so
she'll just be like she'll have like a
plastic bag she's like so where's your
um
container to put the plastic bags and
i'm like
we just throw those out the car window i
don't know i guess we're just
glitter we need to get a recycling bin
uh i'm like just making them into gowns
i know i'm like jesus like she's just
coming with all this like woke shit i'm
like i gotta catch up i'm like
pretending she's like so where's the um
recycling bin i'm like outside
so we got to be on notice we have a 24
year old around us like we got to pull
it together you guys
oh yeah have we done anything
problematic so far all i know is
every day i ask my lawyers for you to
sign a my disclosure agreement and it's
not happening yeah i'm still
i'm free yeah this is risky me being
here right now i don't even think i
signed one
let's talk later the level of
self-respect this one has like we were
working
um and uh she was like well i'm gonna go
make myself some lunch and she was in
the kitchen fully making herself like a
meal i was like what is this next
generation of
people that take care of them i've never
ate ever and i was like i know it's like
fish we eat a nutrigrain in the car like
what is this
so grace is gonna make all of us elevate
i think emily does that too emily is
very good about
managing her own time the other day
emily's like why i have to leave and go
get my laptop like you're just going to
leave
who gave you permission benton will stay
until i'm like go
home something can happen and then we'll
hold up bedroon they'll even like come
back
well i mean what if something exciting
happens and then i missed it because i
was doing something stupid like you're
making a sandwich great
one time i tried to send benton home it
was like nine o'clock at night i was
like
benjamin go home like go and he's like
and do what
i was like watch tv he's like i've been
watching tv my whole life
i was like okay also we were in a hotel
so she was like go home i was like
oh you just want to hang you like me
admit it i do love hanging
so we have a whole new team whole new
year we're gonna pull it together
uh we're gonna be more consistent with
content more consistent with the opens
more consistent with stuff on the good
for you channel
more consistent with the youtube we're
running a business now
fun isn't it fun isn't it exciting they
said we tune in for business oh we're
also redoing the podcast studio sorry
yeah
um uh we're completely redoing this we
need suggestions on what to do behind me
because as grace pointed out this
curtain behind me does look like a
high school theater production um it's
not great the wrinkles have always
annoyed me
but we need to upgrade my background so
yeah so for people listening we just
have a thick blue
yeah yeah let's see it's like a light
blue curtain we're gonna upgrade that
and then we're building
um uh the whole thing out it's just
gonna be fancier we're upgrading
we're fantastic new desk new desk new
curtains on rollers
benton's very um uh grumpy that he
doesn't get a neon sign
there'll be a neon sign somewhere we're
getting a neon sign for you
yeah we do need any unsigned i just
think it's fun okay we have to wrap it
up emily's looking at me emily also is
going to make sure that i make good on
my promise to you guys that i'm not
going to interrupt guests the way that i
have been but i would also like to
interrupt that
to say about interrupting we have to
wrap it up um we are gonna wrap it up
but
whitney interrupts because she's excited
about something and and has a lot to
share
so like let's go a little bit easy on on
the because i'm
i'm on the good for you page i'm getting
a lot of feedback and i really i
appreciate your feedback
but you have to understand that like
she's excited she wants to talk to this
person she has a lot to say
that's why she has a podcast so thank
you emily okay so let's just temper it
and when there is a little too much by
the way the only person i won't
interrupt is emily did you just see that
terrified uh
and we're working on a system where if
it feels like we're we're taking away
from the guest
we're just gonna shoot a nerf dart at
her and um
but you know what it is here's what it
is i get excited and when uh guess like
amanda knox who we flew in i'm like i'm
never going to be able to have this
interview again and i get so excited
but i do if it's frustrating for the
listener experience we are going to fix
it and we are going to do a wrap-up show
with emily benton circling back
where it's called circling back where if
i interrupted a good story
they're going to get it afterwards to
call it guest interrupted guest
interrupted
but also i will say too just to be clear
we filmed the open where i went through
all the
the the criticisms and critiques before
the episodes you've been seeing
so all the comments that are about how
she's not doing it it hasn't started yet
we shot
this is the first one that will happen
since we have done that
i really i really i'm i'm working on it
i'm working on it i hear you
what do you do to dogs again you put
your finger in their butt
just options but we are there's there's
a lot going on we have
new items coming out in may
um we just got a restock on some of your
guys favorites you can go get them
before they are gone
can i just say something really quick
you guys tag yourself in the merch it
just makes my day when you guys tag in
the stories
please keep doing that yes my mom sends
me every single one that i'm tagged in
she sends me a screenshot as if i
haven't already seen it it's so great
she loves it so thank you so much also
um the uh uh bat merch great to puke in
uh i did it for about two weeks yeah
just fyi
you can puke right on it no more no no
no tie-dye i mean mine was covered in
blood and piss
and and puke and no one could really
tell so if you have a grandparent in a
nursing home
a lovely option um if you have trouble
uh keeping salsa
in your mouth this is the hoodie for you
[Laughter]
we're to get back to doing voicemails
yes so please make sure you're leaving
voicemails 818-538-994
every episode we will be listening to a
voicemail
every episode yes every episode and then
community you can still text whitney
she's on community
um her number is 818-239-7527
um you can you can listen you don't have
to send me your message to whitney you
can send them right to her yeah
you know because it all goes to you you
don't have to tell me grace or emily you
can just let her know
because i do check those i have i've
been um sloppy about the birthday
messages for about two months i'm sorry
uh i am gonna get back on board and
grace will make sure that i i do that
we're gonna start playing lots of fun
games we're gonna start doing lots of
wild
crazy things over here and you're gonna
love it all this is the serious part
okay i'm doing real serious listen
this is the part where you need to make
sure that you are following whitney you
are following me you are following the
good for you podcast
you are following on youtube and you're
clicking the little bell so you get
notifications when we upload what does
that mean what little bell
it's a little bell that you get
notifications when we upload yep it
looks it is shaped like a bell
that's a notification it's going to
start doing giveaways once a month once
a month we are doing giveaways
please make sure that you're liking the
videos you're hitting the bell
notification you're sharing them
we're going to start doing a fun thing
where if whenever videos come out we're
going to tweet
instagram about them if you share the
links to those videos we will give you a
shout out we will promote your page
yes and we will be your friend yes and
you know maybe
you will have a pizza party we'll zoom
with you guys suggestions always leave
them on the good for you page the dms
emily's going to be checking those
um i love guest suggestions so please
keep sending us suggestions
yeah we love suggestions also love being
right yeah i love being young
jojo siwa let's do it jojo siwa i know
what that means
queen of the pride parade emma
chamberlain i know what that is what
that
is i know what that is i know what i
think that does
what i think we've met her okay
um let's uh end this love you guys uh
annie letterman is up next we're going
to talk about my covet experience uh it
was harrowing and ridiculous
and we're also going to have dr boris
weissman on the show to answer
our uh covered questions because i'm
confused and i'm sick of
taking my medical advice from comedians
that don't have health insurance so
boris and annie are next
i want to talk about your body hair and
my body hair and what we're doing about
it
i want to be so hairless that i can just
run in jelly and there's nothing left
no little follicles have you ever seen a
hair on my body bunting
um not that i want to talk about
publicly from chin down have you ever
seen a hair on my body
my face is all different not that i want
to discuss it today
i don't think people understand how hard
it is to shave your knees
yeah it's hard to shave in general i can
never get slippery enough
well i'm known for being slippery so
that's not my problem i'm as slippery as
it comes
but every time i shave my knees i'm just
it's carrie at the end of the movie
i'm just in a pool of blood you become
telekinetic
i wish that was my experience full of
blood you can't those curves i have bony
knees i have bony ankles
and i even um have hair on my toes now
but when i use a razor
makes my toes bleed and then i put on
instagram and everyone thinks that i'm
in some really toxic
the first cut is the deepest with billy
i have not had that experience i tried
billy i they sent me one
just for to be nice and i um did try to
shave my legs with it
how'd it go uh wonderfully yeah it was
just it just
went right through there it was not an
issue at all also they're very nice
colors
also i shave my mustache and
oh when it's dry and this is the only
thing that doesn't leave like a little
rash
yeah i mean am i allowed to say that
legally it truly is a great razor i mean
it just it'll cut right through anything
and the shave box
all their products are really good
actually the dry shampoo the shave balm
the face wipes they're all really you
haven't given me the face wipes where
are those i want those
i went and bought them on my own but
this is the only razor i use because i
can't go do the laser i was lasering my
legs that's how
aggressive my hair follicles are uh i
have to go laser but i haven't been able
to because of covid so i'm using this
and this is the only thing where i don't
get out
of the shower and it looks like a murder
happened
yeah back to manual labor because i need
to be able to shave and do like two
other things at the same time and billy
accommodates that for me
i mean billy is just very smart i just
get so bored shaving so boring and you
just
i do it so far isn't it exciting when
you get in the shower and you see
because
because the braces are designed very
beautifully they are colors sexy
mine is a beautiful baby blue and every
time i see it i'm like i should shave
something
i don't even want to i'm going to shave
my head yeah i'm like what should i show
you um
but yeah this is uh look how cute sexy
finally somebody figured out like how to
make it has a magnetic
clip that sticks to the wall that's my
favorite part explain that
in the shower you well you don't have it
here but you stick this magnetic thing
on the wall and it just
right to the wall so it doesn't fall
constantly into your shower you've
been probably not but you're very far
from your bathroom but never been um
asleep at night and you hear like and
then all of a sudden you're like awoken
and something your shower has fallen
that's never happened to anyone why are
you are you just
are you just shampooing so fell in the
shower just teetering your shampoo on
the shelves when you buy bathrooms half
and half
maybe i have a haunted bathroom and
that's my business
but billy's helped out a lot and to
express a little love from our show go
to mybilly.com
whitney it's a small way you can support
us while getting the best razor you will
ever own
it's just nine doll hairs and you get
your own starter kit plus
free shipping always go to mybilly.com
whitney
spelled my b i l i e dot com
slash whitney a lot of people in the new
year
they're like i'm gonna eat better not me
i'm gonna eat
and doordash accommodates that yeah yeah
doordash
they'll come right to your house they
will safely drop off whatever
you feel like you're the queen of
versailles only downside they won't say
any of the food with you
no have you asked i've tried i've been
like do you have any friends they're
like actually i'm good
um okay 300 000 partners in the puerto
rico canada u.s and australia i know
that because i'm a big fan
one of my favorite places to order from
cheesecake factory
oh you know why because they have every
food but it could truly be the only
place on the menu it is
wild that they have so much food that
you never have left for
cheesecake encyclopedia of meals
you can try it for yourself for a
limited time our listeners get 25 off
and zero
delivery fees in their first order of
fifteen dollars or more when you
download the doordash app
and enter the code whitney 2021
uh that's 25 off and up to 10 value
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store
on my home page whitney 2020 on my home
page why is it so funny to me don't
forget
that's code 2021 for 25 off your first
order with doordash
subject to change terms apply first
guest of 2021
is the great annie letterman it's
leaderman no it's not no it's letterman
i hate you
i was about to say pronounced it right
how often does that happen
do you know what i did chelsea lately
she pronounced my name
i was amy lieberman once i was later men
there was no i mean it was so
unbelievable and she would never retake
it so i just like that's
i'm amy that's me it's so hard to get
successful and people cannot get your
last name right
i would be so famous if people would
just be consistent with my name well i
kept thinking that if people get my
last name wrong it's really on me i just
have i'm not famous enough
i never can came out of you um
are we friends are we
you tell me you tell me you tell me
bitch tell me i don't know bitch
i didn't know you had covet until you
announced it on a
zoom with 17 other people not proud of
this
i'm not proud of this so i did have
kovid i have annie on the show to
uh shame her to
uh gently tell everyone what happened i
was diagnosed the 24th
my christmas present was kovid um i
think santa
and god um and uh
yeah and we didn't talk for like three
weeks
but in general pre-covet are we friends
i want everyone to have context of our
relationship
100 well i love you annie comics are so
sensitive and we're so mean to each
other
why do we do this we're funny we're the
most sensitive people and all we do is
just beat the shit out of each other
well it's just
i think it's fun because with us it's
always like like to the edge to the edge
to the edge across the boundary too far
i don't too far too much apart
it's like fine and then there's a call
back where it's like that actually
wasn't okay yeah you know it's like
i need five minutes to be like too much
yeah too far
yeah but it's i don't know i think it's
fun i think it's fun to make fun of each
other
everything's a joke and whenever i take
things seriously personally it's like
that's embarrassing because we all need
to be willing to
take a hit for the group laughter is how
i feel yeah
but i mean you know but then if someone
calls me like esther
esther will um call me sometimes and be
like ah that just felt weird when you
said that thing
i don't know why we're good at
downloading our feelings yeah we're
pretty good about that and if you don't
then you'll build resentment and fucking
hate each other
yeah but you have such a you're so um
you have such
uh you're so emotionally intelligent
like you'll
will get in a thing and you'll be like
sorry my inner child came out
like how do you know all that i just
work on myself a lot i try i just
i have a lot of anger problems or i have
had in the past
and i just try to work on it how so i
just how do i work on it how do you what
kind of anger
well i had an outburst i was so upset
well you know i had
i got a stomach ulcer i have
construction in my apartment building
so all surrounding all apartments is
just it's just
from 7 30 in the morning on it's just
insane
inconsistent pounding don't
underestimate how
stressful it is to have construction in
your building right
no it's really i didn't know it would
it's how i mean it's a form of torture
yeah it is literally how they torture
people in some parts just not on rhythm
like there's no beat tonight
no it's erratic all my shit was like
getting knocked off the wall it was just
crazy it's a nightmare
and also just random fucking dudes it's
your home it's your home
and it's so crazy so that was happening
my puppy got
mange and then all his eye hair fell out
it was his eyes were like bleeding and
then all his eye hair fell out
20 20 is a nightmare it was just like so
much was going on yeah
and i got a stomach ulcer and i was
freaking out and
um i got the new iphone i ordered the
new iphone and i was like this is going
to be
my it's so embarrassing i'm like this is
going to be my light at the end of the
tunnel like
my new iphone is going to be i'll become
a vlogger it'll be great
i get the box for my iphone it's an
empty fucking box
which now i can it's from apple someone
where did you order from
someone in amazon just undid because
when i put it into the light you could
see that they had re
they could just tell from where it was
coming that it was an iphone and someone
just stole it out of the thing and it
was
thanksgiving eve so everything was
closed i couldn't get a hold of anyone
so i'm just like and it was on my
podcast like todd handed it to me and i
open and i'm like
this is light we gotta go this is thank
you we'll see you next week you know
and then i just was like another thing i
was just feeling like this pity party
for myself
and being such a victim and then in the
morning
i was talking to my friend and she was
like you know you're probably gonna have
to go
um to the police station and tell them
like i'm not going to the fucking
and i just started freaking out and i
threw my working phone
and i was like smashing it until bro
like it wasn't breaking and i was like
smashing it and smashing and smashing it
and then i just had this phone that
didn't work and i was like looking at it
my friend was like
call me about she her face was like
breaking up there was like green lines
going she was like
call me on todd's phone and um
it was just so much i just got so
enraged and was freaking out and then
there nothing good came out of it you
know i just burn i talked about this
yeah
like i i get it i get rage i have rage
come up
and it's it's just for me it's a sign
that i need to be working on myself
and doing stuff so then what does
working on yourself mean what's your
daily working on myself
well there's nothing daily i have 80d
it's trying it's like i am attempting
daily
for three days it's three days i mean i
can't tell you how many books i've read
like three pages of yeah
i'm like i've i've once i get through
the roman numeral
numerals i'm like there's more numbers
like i went through the letters are you
fucking kidding me
these hieroglyphics yeah but it's you
know so
what i do try to do what does help me is
breath work and meditation helps me out
breath work what does that mean
breath work is so embarrassing i like
that it's such a i'm just saying i just
i feel like people throw these terms
around i just want to get granular on
what it means and how it's helped you
granular
like i'm doing my breath work it's like
what does that even talking mean
granular what does that mean um get
specified
oh don't actually answer badge post
covet i actually know some vocabulary
she went to ben we got it
ivy league bitch my college went out of
business yours is the most popular
wait can you explain that to people i
went to the college of santa fe in new
mexico
and it was a small liberal arts school
it was
and it took me eight years to get my
undergrad which i never would have
gotten i had all these incompletes eight
years
yes i just stopped going and i was like
incomplete
because i'm good at charming my
professors so i would go in and be like
i used to tell them i would come and
they'd be like you missed your midterms
oh i thought they were my terms i just
do them whatever i want and they're like
are you well are you okay
and so i had all these income are you
okay any i am okay and people do ask me
that a lot and it is michael
jackson reference um and we still listen
to michael jackson on the good for your
podcast
as long as it's already been downloaded
no new downloads yeah you can't that's
our rule
r kelly michael jackson if you've
already downloaded it you get to listen
to it no
new downloads no new money to the estate
that's the rule
like there's any person in the world
that's just being introduced to michael
jackson
like i saw this really crazy documentary
about this guy i think he's a singer
the music's pretty good the kids were
sliding their buttholes and backing them
up and he was like
and then it made me want to google him
and then the guy has some bob
yeah like he's really good i like his
dance moves they're so cool
um but yeah does that feel right does
that feel right in terms of
uh canceled people listening to their
work if you've already downloaded it
it's fine
yeah i think that covers the basis i
don't know it's like the cancelling
thing's so weird
but because i do believe in redemption
too and
but some of the stuff is so bad i have a
hot take on cancel culture
let's hear it comedians are creating all
this yeah
it's not real it's us yeah and we talk
about we are
so mentally ill we are such chronic
victims
that we are we are so desperate to have
people hate us to have our insides match
our outsides
that we were like inventing this giant
cancel culture narrative
not i'm not talking about i'm talking
about it a lot i'm not talking about
rape i'm not talking about minors every
comedian opens with
no one lets me say this it's like you
were never
talking about you you did jokes about
airplane food for the last 35 years
say it in your house yeah so comedians
will complain about literally
anything coming from the people that
like complain about hot pockets like
i get into that too it's a it's a victim
mentality and you also can choose to not
be canceled i mean it's what
you lose your sponsors you like lose
some followers
but you what do you just stop or do you
i
i don't know it's like you're not going
to prison you're not
what are you you're it's like a choice
comedians we're dramatic by nature
we're dramatic for a living like i feel
like we're the ones that are
perpetuating this narrative we
definitely talked about take
hot take i like that take is it real i
mean i think you are you trying to get
cancelled
i feel like i've been canceled for so
long i feel like i'm on borrowed time
anyway
but do you think you have enough money
to get cancelled defined
i have such a scarcity complex like i
grew up without money
and i still like i got the sweater off
etsy i still won't spend money on
expensive shit
yeah i'll spend money on experiences how
much was that though on etsy because
etsy has a range it could be expensive
this oh yeah
so vintage t-shirts actually are wildly
exorbitant
um this was probably like 12 dollars
and i paid too much let's be honest
i'm wearing a sweater with uh how would
you describe the sweater anyway it's
like
for a young child it's a little bit
like there's rain it's like christmasy
and um there's cute little elephants
yeah i don't know it's very juvenile you
can tell the age you were possibly
molested
[Laughter]
i feel like annie that's where we really
bonded over being molested
i just can't shut up about it when you
know when someone else can joke about
being molested
it's just the best i just can't stop
talking about it when someone has the
same level of sexual abuse as you it's
just the best
i love i'll get comments sometimes that
are like she talks so much about being
and i'm like
they're like i wish she would stopped
i'm like yeah i wish i would stop
telling myself the story too
i really would like to be move on from
this but that's actually something in
you being molested i know i'm over it me
too
um but i during the pandemic i've done a
lot of like meditation
and stuff and gotten kind of over my
shit and then it'll pop back up i'll
have ptsd switches
what do you mean but i just i just i've
done a lot of work on
i did a breath work and the breath work
that i do
is through this shaman i have a shame
i'm shami's panama's favorite oh no
does rogan twice does rogan twice now
she has a shirt no i did it
i did it before rogan and you know i
didn't dare bring it up on rogan
yeah i don't bring up ayahuasca but um
i did some breath work that where it was
a
meditation uh where they were like
you're go to some woods and so i'm in
the woods
hold on you're telling me okay for the
listeners if you want to do breath work
you do not have to go to the website no
you don't have to no i'm not in the
woods this is in the meditation
okay so it's a meditation i did where it
was like go to the woods
and visually okay right basically pick
some woods okay and i would always pick
and i just went
to the suicide forest in japan
this is a rorschach test i failed okay
so woods like what kind of woods
so i you can pick any woods but i would
always pick the woods outside my high
school where i had traumatizing
experiences why would you go those ones
i don't know because i was still living
in it so then i go to the woods
and this is so does anything good ever
happen in any woods
um can't be back
you know sometimes you have noisy
neighbors
um yeah camping spelunking does that
happen in the woods
i don't know are there caves and woods i
don't know um
but so i'm in the meditation i'm at the
in the woods
at my high school just not even thinking
about it just like automatically going
there
and then us an animal comes to and
speaks to you
kind of animal i had a wolf my spirit
animal was
just a wolf came up to me and the wolf
started talking this is not on ios cause
this is fully
super and the wolf was like let's get
out of these woods let's not come back
to these woods anymore and i was like oh
shit i realized how much i was
revisiting all my shit
and i kept bringing it up and it's like
oh i can just kind of like
move on which i try to do but sometimes
i have
relapses and stuff but it's tricky
because we really and this is really
like 2021
um new year new us
she said that earlier i was like it's
new year new maybe it's like what oh
right sorry
our new year new year i'm like she's so
codependent that was such a codependent
relapse
new year new us um yeah i mean i really
like
and we'll talk about me having cove in a
second but it's like it really is just
like divorcing yourself from like how
attached are we to our narrative
of like our victimhood yeah you know
like
it's a tricky one well it just sucks to
keep going there just like why do i have
to drag this fucking
like just it's like taking stuff out of
your backpack but at the same time it's
like we don't want to minimize what
happened
to us but we also don't want to
exaggerate and re-traumatize ourselves
why do i have to relive this all the
time and i've ever i realized every
podcast i go on now they're
they go like hey so the theme as you
show up you've never met the person they
go the theme is the worst thing that's
ever
happened to you go and i'm like what i
don't want to yeah yeah people need to
keep hearing
oh my god it's so fucking true do people
need to keep hearing this and i get the
idea why do comedians have to bomb for
two hours on their podcast
when did podcasts become just everybody
talk about their trauma for two hours
like why aren't we allowed to be funny
anymore i don't are we allowed
we're only allowed to talk about
politics and trauma i know it's just so
dark and but i mean i have punchlines in
my stories but
i just it's like i'm over i don't like
who is this what is this for
and even what people like it's an
important story to tell it's like to who
i know
i think that's been my major thing like
like
like getting close with you has been so
healing for me because i felt like
um this whole like me too uh moment
everyone's like well you have to tell
your story it's like i'll do whatever
the fuck i want
yeah whenever the to me that's like the
worst
uh example to set that you're telling
trauma survivors that they have to
behave a certain way i'm going to think
independently
i want to talk more about our friendship
okay okay so when did we become friends
so then we became friends did you not
like me before we met because i was
scared of you but
i'm obsessed with the way women perceive
each other before they met
before they knew each other and the way
we project onto each other
and then when they become friends like i
used to think you were such a bitch like
i thought you were a scary
bitch that didn't like me cut two
pandemic happens and i think that
i did like you before the pandemic no no
we had already bonded i also just love
you because you're just like a
real comic you know it's like you know
a lot of i don't know it's it's
interesting because it's like
you know i go on the road and there's
just such a dissonance between
what this like twitter versus saying
people want to hear versus what comics
no people want to hear
and i feel like there's this like mass
infantilization
of comedy fans right now where like
people can't handle this or
yeah they can we're comics if you don't
think something's funny it's funny or
it's not
yeah right straight up yeah um
i also very quickly realized that you
are incredible
with relationship advice you are so
clear you are so cogent like you're so
good at that oh thanks
so i've i mean i just have gone through
so many fucking terrible relationships
but all of them have given me really
good lessons
i mean my my probably my worst breakup
was my best
like if i look back on all the lessons i
learned i had a boyfriend who
really taught me like who my worth it
was so crazy and i guess
he just was like he just laid it out for
me he was like oh
when this person's being that way it's
because you're coming in with like
goddess vibes what was embarrassing this
was like a couple years ago i don't want
to out who it is because
we don't talk about the past and
whatever but
it was just um i had really low
self-esteem
and and maybe that came off everyone
always like thinks i'm very confident
when
i guess i have a type of confidence but
it just
so i would have so i would get so hurt
by people and i think they just assumed
i could
i didn't have those feelings that's can
we talk about that
yeah there's a difference between loud
and confident
yeah i think people think because i'm
loud that i'm super strong and super
confident and i'm like invincible
like no i just have a low register of my
voice i can't control that
nobody thinks you're invincible now
bitch with all your bites and stuff
it looks like somebody's a voodoo doll
against you and it's just stabbing it
every day
like you pissed someone off you are
fucked up
dude it's wild but like i always know
you'll be okay though i i mean
every time a new picture would come up
i'm like ah she'll end up looking hotter
she'll figure something out
she'll find the doctor to fix it she'll
come and come in but don't you think
like i i feel like we're so similar in
this way and that we're both people that
come
off very tough but we're both very
sensitive people and it's hard for
people to love yeah
and i but i want to be taught i mean i
would like to be tough but it's it was
funny i went camping over the
summer and i really because of my
brothers i
try so hard to be like i'm not scared of
fucking spite like
put up you know and i would always
overcompensate and be like putting like
a spider on my feet like look it's fine
i don't give a shit but inside i'm
panicking
mm-hmm i feel like trying to be funny
and trying to entertain yeah just trying
to be like whatever i don't care i'm not
scared of things and then
i had to cut a worm and there's a video
i gotta post it to cut a worm just to
cut a worm and have to go
fishing and i started screaming so like
the girliest scream and i'm like
there's me like there's like you know
because i just think there's a lot of
just having brothers i just had to be
and my mother
have to like develop this exoskeleton to
be tough i mean most of it's my
mother issues honestly it's either my
mom or my dad every time i anything one
thing it's your mother
i'm like mom or dad one mom which one
but
i think a lot of that is for my mom
because my mom was very rejecting a
femininity so i had to be very
how so um she just
was always encouraging like she just
wanted sports and
and stuff like that and she would always
talk about when she was a kid she hated
she wanted sports
she just i don't know how to what does
that even mean she just would be gonna
just let you say that sentence yes i'm
the one that hykovid i know but i'm the
one who's college we're not about i
don't know i don't know that much about
sports but i'm pretty sure that's not
how you say it
okay so my mom was she
my mom was adopted which i think a lot
of all of my
inherited issues come from a lot of that
sort of
mother wound that you have when your
fucking
mom doesn't raise you that is pretty
wild yeah i think it was really tough
for me so your grandmother was
my my my mom never met her birth parents
and then her
mother was dying when my mom was 15 at
boarding school was diagnosed with
ovarian cancer and given six months to
live my mom wasn't allowed to come home
and then she ended up living 15 years
and then died
when my mom was pregnant with me and my
twin brother so
she had like 15 years of feeling her mom
was gonna die whenever
and then she did die when my mom really
really needed her so i just think i just
think
the act of being adopted was something
that really hurt her and then
all these other things so i really very
much understand my mom but she was
always would be
you know tell stories about when she was
a kid she was like i want to go play
put my hair up in a hat and try to play
baseball with the boys and they'd be
like scram girl and i'm like i think
that was just like the
league of their own i don't know if that
really happened mom
was rosie donald playing you um and
it reminds me can we watch riding the
bus with my sister
oh do you remember that movie are we
allowed to watch that is that what
you're saying are we allowed to watch
no remember when rosie o'donnell played
someone with down syndrome and riding a
bus with my sister
i don't remember i just like to make
sure we're all
still bringing up things that you know
that rosie's roasting i'm just i just
like to i just like to never forget
she's like an elephant um so
um but anyway yeah i just so my mom was
always talking about sports how she want
to play baseball and stuff and then i
joined the baseball team and she
traded me off the team with men boys
baseball team yeah
to impress my mom and then she traded me
to like another it was just so
i mean i can't even tell you just i've
been pretty much chasing my mom
for a million years and she's still
there and loves me and stuff but it's i
realized
that i just i just it gets me every once
in a while just get like down why am i
talking about this
no but i think it's important because
something because but it's like my
relationship with women is weird but i
was
oh with masculinity and stuff so my mom
would she just was rejecting
if i had dolls she'd be like i never
like dolls i don't know what you're
seeing them so i would have to make them
like fuck and shoot each other
i'd be like no they're doing boy things
you know so i was like kind of
always had i was like anything girly was
bad
so i was raised with this sort of be a
boy
yeah i kind of had that too and it more
came from my dad
because i think he and you know it was
just awkward i mean that generation just
didn't have a lot of tools like my
you know my dad was just like like had a
son and then had two daughters and it
just was like
weird you know and he kind of just like
threw a basketball at me
you know that's the only way we could
bond was like through sports so i kind
of became a
tomboy just like yeah did you throw it
at you like hit you in the hands
like over and over and over again wait a
second
um epiphany i was abused
um but no but just something that i love
about you and something that you've
really helped me
um with in terms of just like my
emotional growth is like you seem like
you
really understand that your your primary
caretakers were wounded also
and you seem to have like radical
forgiveness for your parents like that's
my new shit is like radical forgiveness
for our parents yeah i mean well also
my parents are old and i don't want like
my baby mom who's
the younger one my dad's 79 my mom just
turned 70.
that was like a huge wake up your mom's
70. okay yeah mine's probably around
there
yeah so i'm and i'm just you know i just
think about it's like they're going to
be i don't want to be mad at them and a
lot of shit happened
there was a lot of shit in my life that
was where they really let me down
and it's just but i just have to like i
have made me funny bitch
i'm like at the point where i'm just
like it made me funny it made me funny
made me funny it made me funny
and it made me strong and i just have to
be fine with it and it's but you know
stuff comes up and i just have to
manage it why are we both dating younger
men because they're the best
they do everything for are you our
pussies are so tight and tiny
so cute they do everything
they do but i think i have a theory as
someone
uh uh you're dating your i'm dating i
think all this shit worked
like all the tweets all the me too all
the insta i don't know what it is
but the younger guys are respectful they
like women
it's so funny because we have so many
friends guy friends who are freaking out
during this time
why are you freaking out there's a type
of guy that is fucking feels guilty
so they're nervous it's coming for them
and
then but like my i'm only dating guys uh
i date
the age i pick now is just someone that
couldn't have raped someone in the 90s
the key is they weren't born
yeah no it's it's it's nice but it's you
know it's just
and my boyfriend's like that like he
would never there's no he doesn't have
it like gentle and sweet he is just
but what is that why are younger guys
sweeter because they could probably
aren't all they would probably because i
thought it was going to be younger guys
they grew up on porn they're going to
beat the shit out of you it was like
completely the opposite experience i was
like oh god i'm going to have to like
put a ball gag in my like here we go
like a 31 year old guy this is going to
be a nightmare
like you've shown me some of the nudes
you send and they're about i'm like
why'd you go bondage first
where have you been what's going on no
but it's like it's it's not
um like i didn't even know you owned
duct tape
i um uh uh i anticipated that younger
guys like
my i postulated in i mean i talked about
my specials years ago i was like
the guys are gonna get worse and worse
they're gonna hate women more and more
because they're watching porn
um and then i'm like hooking up with
this 31 year old he's so respectful and
it's
like kind of annoying
i'm like i don't know bitch can you well
it's like it doesn't have the same
excitement as one of these really scary
like i've dated guys that are fucking
scary yeah i was dating gang members
when i was 14 i was like sneaking out of
my house
and going to the roosevelt mall and
getting guys pager numbers and like
yeah calling fucking um movie phones so
the phone wouldn't be i would page them
and i'd be on movie phone so then the
call waiting would come and it wouldn't
wake my parents up and then i would have
legit gang members pick me up
and take me wherever i remember we
climbed in through the window
we went to this uh swimming in this pool
in philly and we climbed in the window i
was like why are we going through the
window they're like oh none of us live
here we're just like breaking and
entering i'm 14. i told them i was 16.
um they were like i don't know how old
and then at one point they came to get
me and they got all got arrested
and the guy i had been hooking up with
was wanted for fucking homicide
i'd only hang out with them twice but
it's like i was in danger i dated
dangerous guys and i
so when i did that young that became my
type
so then i was dating these guys where i
felt unsafe and it's like i don't
i value comfort and safety and secure
attached men
it's so nice it's not as exciting but
you're not gonna die explain
that i mean that's what my uh uh
therapist said to me once she was like
um
if you're bored that's probably just
serenity
you know that's probably just secure
attachment style yeah like a guy that
you're just like i mean that's the thing
is all we do is complain that there are
no nice guys then we get one and we're
like oh i'm so
bored yeah well it's there's no risk i
mean i was bored when i went skydiving i
thought it was boring i was like this is
it
i was i always want to say like next
time i go skydiving i want to make sure
they have one star on yelp
and then when we go up they're like
there's two parachutes one works chews
or it's like adrenaline junkie yeah
totally and it's it's unhealthy when i
got so mad about my cell phone like a
fucking
cycle over a phone and then smashed my
only other phone i have no contacts
but um i have no contact i don't know
any i've people text i'm like i have no
clue you are
but um when i got some like it takes too
much out of me i don't want to do that
anymore i don't like that
that that release of anger it just
it's too when i get hot like to the red
zone it's just not i don't like it i
don't want it
yeah so now it's just about managing
that and not getting triggered it's like
the world around me is not going to
change i have to adapt
right i have to handle my shit i have no
control over anyone else
can i bring up an uncomfortable topic
i'm trying to work on a bit about this
because i mean obviously i've said is
that why it's uncomfortable
why you're like it's a really unfunny
bit that's why it's uncomfortable yeah
uh excuse me like bomb for the next 20
minutes no but i'm working on a bit
about this
i feel like i've been very clear about
my values in terms of like predatory
behavior and
um that said
when i was 16 i dated a 35 year old
that was just how it was back then what
what do we make of that
i don't think it was i dated my
professors i dated older guys like what
do we do with that
i don't think it was the way it was back
then i think there just wasn't social
media to out it
i think that that not everyone had those
experiences i think when you have crazy
fucked up experiences i
the past couple of years is when i
realized oh everyone didn't have these
yeah like people had parents that were
like eating like i'm always like if you
ate dinner with your parents every night
i'd
have nothing to say to you i know people
are like we used to scream at the dinner
table like dinner table yeah what are
you talking about you guys
ate together i mean we did sometimes
like psychos
we got pizza but um yeah it's
you know i i don't know i i think that
people are able to talk more i you know
it's not
maybe all these bad behaviors were
happening i definitely
you know went to a high school where oh
i keep finding out every teacher was
molesting every kid i'm like oh it
wasn't just me
yeah wow all the teachers were fucking
us cool
um the only thing more traumatic than
being molested by a teacher is finding
out that they molested other students no
there's a couple that
didn't even know well no there's a
couple students that didn't even know
they were molesting i'm like that
you are so ugly i'm so sorry they were
fucking
all of us all of us it's like two people
like wait why we never heard about this
it it's also a little it is
i don't know it's a little uncomfortable
like i was trying to do a bit why wasn't
this working
about uh the catholic church it's just
too awk
like no one really talks about it like
we don't i mean there was
spotlight uh yeah there was a movie okay
yeah everyone talks about it i was just
it's your joke bitch you're like
nobody's talking about this
i was just yelling okay so the premise
didn't work i just i just feel like
everyone's talking about i just feel
like
yeah molested nobody gives a shit is
that a hot day
i care didn't come to me little broken
boys
no i like good boys now healthy boys no
but i'm really into this um
dating younger they grew up with beyonce
they saw oprah like they respect women
it's just different
they're a different vibe how did junior
guy meet
um he was an editor i met him through do
you want kids
maybe i think about i've had to detach
myself from the outcome because you
won't freeze my eggs but
i am happy to freeze your eggs for you
annie let's do it
i will i will do this but i'm i'm trying
to set it up as a tv show
i love her honestly it's brilliant it's
brilliant what i just like how your mind
works it's
because i can look at you and go okay
we're similar in age
i'm 66. you're six i'm 65.
you know you're older than me mm-hmm and
you went to penn i grew up and my dad
worked at penn i mean it's like we have
like similar areas right stuff yeah
i am paycheck to paycheck panicking
how do i put like what's the difference
the difference is your brain
goes to work and mine goes like how can
i not work like what can i do to get the
fuck out of work
and yours is like how do i turn
everything into a business i
want to turn everything into a business
so i like that which is why my immune
system is always trash
no i mean you did go fucking hard you've
been going hard yeah
non-stop um what but would you ever
adopt
after my mom oh interesting oh
no i would maybe i would i have no clue
what has she done to 23andme or anything
have you done that
my brother did and we were all excited
we thought we were gonna find like my
mom's family and we just found
this guy my this like uncle of my dad's
that he just stopped talking to and then
i just get emails like chain emails now
for my
herman lederman like jesus christ
she's like oh my god but yeah no and my
mom doesn't really want i don't know if
she wants to find her birth parents or
not or i mean they're probably not alive
anymore but
i think she's like her parents were
great and she doesn't she never wanted
to
offend them or do stuff like that but
um it is weird when i did ayahuasca i
thought about that i was like thinking
about the lineage and like
how many times have you done ayahuasca
i've done like four two weekends and
four times and did you go in
like explain for people that are like on
the fence about doing it like
what was your experience like why did
you do it and
how was it medicinal for you i felt
really
you know i just i've been dealing with
my demons and i was just
really itching to do it i had done dmt a
couple times smoked dmt
and really was unbelievable so beautiful
and incredible
and i knew that ayahuasca was a similar
it's like dmt but then the ayahuasca
route
extends it so it goes for four hours
really did you puke the first i did i
would ask them one time
i peeked well it's so funny because i
remember talking to you the first time
that was bulimia
that was defender prom jobs yeah yeah um
no but
we talked to the comedy store once and
you were like yeah i did ayahuasca i
didn't get anything out of it i was like
you didn't have such an amazing
experience and i explained my experience
i was like
i was thinking about my dad i just have
such an anxious attached
uh love style
and i just you know i was at the time
dating this guy and he he was i was just
feeling like i couldn't tell if he liked
it and i was just feeling so like
obsessed with it
and i couldn't get out of my head and i
was feeling so unloved and let down and
all this stuff and
um i want to do ayahuasca and i just was
in the main room had done a show
got off stage i saw these two people
they were like really cool there was
something like
sweet about them and the guy high-fived
me and then later i found out that they
were there visiting
the general manager and he was did he
was an ayahuasca
shaman and he was in town during a
weekend and he had come to the comedy
store a couple times and i was his
favorite comedian
and he's gay so it was real um i was at
first i was like he's trying to fuck me
he's like he's gay i was like oh my god
a dream
i'll turn it on i'll turn them but
he had like seen me and i had just found
like we had just gravitated to each
other and i had
already put out like that i want i was
like i really want ayahuasca but you
can't
find it it's not a thing you can find
and so then they're like we had a drop
out this weekend why don't you just
cancel
like how does how do people find
ayahuasca in the real world i just i
think you just have to set an intention
and hope it comes to you
really i the first i did not get
anything out of it i was right after my
dad had died the first night i felt
nothing
i'm really weird on drugs some drugs do
like absolutely nothing for me and some
of them just like
i'm off the grid edibles i think we can
all agree are not crazy they're not my
drug
weed for me is so edibles are not my
drug they're not my drug
the first time i did edibles was when my
ear got bitten off
by a dog i went to mexico with a guy
that i met on mariah
um and my friend calls that rich asshole
young asshole
ryan that's so funny this is the dating
app for
um like what is it for like
photographers who wear v-necks and have
man buns like i don't even know what
this app is
at any uh anymore but um uh
i didn't want to take painkillers
because i'm so afraid of the addiction
in my family and painkillers i was like
i'm gonna take edibles
and my brain was like this is like the
healthy painkiller um
new year's eve bridget everett's there
i'm there with michael patrick king
the guy i met on raya uh who else was
there i mean there are witnesses to this
i'm not exaggerating i took the entire i
don't know what 25
mgs means i'm not a doctor like i don't
know
like i don't know what i need i take the
whole thing
i fainted uh at the buffet
holding a handful of salad and a marrow
bone
is that so annoying that she just had
salad we get your skinny bitch
even even when she's got the munchies
she's going for this arugula
she's just fucking like over eating
salad
um and then uh that what was the other
time i did it like i just
when i take an edible my brain says that
edible didn't work you need to take 10
more
i get way too generous on weed i get
very generous i start writing checks
i start um start i started a couple
businesses
like i just we i tried weed over the
pandemic
not for me sober off weed right now it's
so bad and by the way i
am always looking for a reason to
relapse on any drug ever so the minute
you were like
i took edibles i like looked at todd and
i was like let's smoke weed tonight
and then i had to fucking stop it makes
me insane like i think my anger gets so
i just get so paranoid it makes me
paranoid yeah
doubting yourself it's just not it's
just not for me it's just not for me and
i'm sure like for everyone out there i'm
sure there's like a strain that's good
for me right oh i hate when you say i
don't smoke and people
you just need a strong strain you need
the purple rice krispies i'm like get
the fuck out of here i'm 38 years old
they're like you just need the purple
rain lollipop i'm like i don't need any
of this shit i need an advil
i need somebody i need some vitamin c
she needs a hug
i know she's a hug and a dog i need to
go talk to my therapist to go to an
aladdin meeting let's be honest
uh we now take a break in uh annie
letterman yelling at me
on the podcast uh to talk about beds
linen linens brook linen to be exact
someone who has uh been one of the
grandpas in the charlie in the chocolate
factory
for the past three weeks uh someone
who's been in bed for
a month straight i don't know what i
would have done without brooklyn
brooklyn and truly is one of those i
mean i almost didn't show up today it
was so comfortable
i was like i'd rather just stay here
honestly you can wake up in a cold sweat
in brooklyn and cheat still comfortable
because i've been doing that for the
last two weeks
i speak from experience even when
they're cold and wet
still cozy as hell i mean they are a
luxury sheet and they're not they don't
cost like
a trillion dollars like they're very
affordable which is why i feel that i
can
you know not go to my job and sleep in
because i've already bought the sheets
sheets are a racket
brooklyn is not yeah and not only that
but they have like they have pillows
they have
towels they have loungewear what yeah
you can literally
wear the sheets instead of instead of
being like me where you wrap yourself up
in a toga
you can be like buy their lounge you can
be like emily and you can turn the white
sheets into a wedding dress
and you can sort of walk around your
house and pretend that you should show
up on your ex-boyfriend's porch
you can reenact bride wars the way i do
play ann and kate i do both
you can turn the pillowcases into a fake
veil and have fake weddings
in your bedroom i have a pair of white
sheets and off-white i can cry
right through them they dry instantly
they are tear proof
it's a very sad slumber but not with
brook linen it's 20 21
do something nice for yourself to start
the new year to help do that brook linen
has a special offer
go to brooklyn.com and use promo code
whitney that's b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
and enter promo code whitney to get 25
off when you spend 100 or more plus free
shipping
brooklyn.com and use promo code whitney
at checkout
ready oh
nailed it what's that the sound of
benton my ribs cracking
because i didn't drink enough lollipop a
healthy alternative soda
um first of all it's a sparkling tonic
how dare you first of all it tastes just
like soda
it's which is the point but it's healthy
for my digestive system which i don't
know if you know goes through a lot well
no as someone that's been on antibiotics
you ever talked to my digestive system
i'm not sad it's it's gurgled at me a
couple times angrily
nostalgic flavors which one's your
favorite but hold on go back to the fact
that this has
prebiotics yeah this is like grazing
yeah but
as someone that has been on antibiotics
for the past six months i would like to
say that this has been a godsend for
just to clarify these drinks are not
antibiotics
no i am they are not an alternative to
doctor no i've been on antibiotics and
you're supposed to take
probiotics and prebiotics when you're on
it because you fight little wars in your
stomach yes
to restore uh uh the piece in your gut
just to get back to balance
so that you don't get a yeast infection
and something horrible the idea of you
taking probiotics
antibiotics and be like we'll see who
wins
we'll figure it out i'm like i'm like a
russian emperor at the gladiator show
i'm like let's see what you got
one of you were so esther our friend is
who initially turned us
on to this lollipop it is so you know
what i just love the packaging it is so
twee and quaint and charming and uh
comforting with the nostalgia doesn't it
just look like you're running down
packaging get a phosphate in the 40s
the cherry vanilla is my very favorite
it makes me feel like i'm in a lana del
rey song
the strawberry vanilla is my favorite
because it makes me feel like um oh no
don't get me started on the beetles you
know that's triggering well this
also you know these drinks have uh very
little sugar in them
only two to five grams of sugar i'm just
annoyed that i haven't had this my whole
life like the fact that
i've been drinking uh trash soda my
entire life and then now at 38 years old
they've
an event one that's like healthy and
good and delicious they're also non-gmo
vegan paleo keto friendly they have only
eight net carbs
that's a lot of um i'm not really sure
what's in that drink to be honest with
you
mm-hmm that could be water just
delicious
delicious it's truly really delicious
and we've worked out an exclusive deal
for good for you podcast listeners
receive 20 off plus free shipping on the
best-selling variety pack
this is a great way to try all the
delicious flavors go to drink lollipop
dot com slash whitney and use code
whitney and check out to claim this deal
that's d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i-p-o-p
dot com whitney this discount is only
valid for their variety pack
lollipop can also be found in over 3 000
stores across the country
including whole foods sprouts kroger
that one i can never say in irwin
wegmans
i had covered let's talk about it um
my what did you what did you think was
happening so i had heard a rumor
like a couple weeks in because when you
weren't you're very active
whitney has about 5 000 different chat
threads in her phone and when you're not
hitting any of them
i give it one day where i go did she
just make a new one without me in it
i'm like no and then i so i figured
something was going on i mean it was
also new year it was christmas eve i'm
trying to think about
it was christmas eve i was like
tomorrow's christmas i didn't want to
like ruin people's christmas i didn't
want to make
it about me it was just such a and
because we had done those distant
stand-up shows we had done
those distance influencer parties we did
that distance screening for the craft we
did the distance things i can't believe
you called them influencer parties what
were they
transparent what were they a bunch of
fun people hanging out and some of them
have 25 million followers yeah
my you just hang out with my friends um
uh and like well i mean i guess i'm
i internalized people's criticism of me
i guess yeah
um but uh you know i i was like uh if i
say it now everyone's
like well of course you got it but the
ice i gotta be honest i stand by those
like we were safe no one got covered
from those
um i know people were like yeah because
whitney was like in target pulling her
mask down like
i didn't get it from that i'm like i
feel like i'm the first person to
say like yeah guys i'm a karen i pulled
my mask down to target and i got it
don't do it you definitely weren't even
meaning to do it it's so funny you just
were like talking so much that you
didn't realize you didn't have to pull
your legs
my biggest fear in life is not being
heard and wearing a mask is like my
living nightmare no i know it's hell
um and uh do you know that i didn't hear
feel any of the earthquakes last year
because i was talking through all of
them
like dead serious uh people i'm like i
missed another one
i thought i was like killing people were
bracing themselves for the cool ending
to my story
i just talked through every single one
of them um and i also wanted to like
and also by the way i was in so much
pain i did have a very bad experience
with
like i had from the experiences i've
heard one of the worst i also uh
concurrently had a uti which is just so
dumb
yeah just so stupid and because it
causes inflammation
it exacerbated that so i just had a very
extreme case
and i thought i was like going crazy and
i just didn't want to like
blast out stuff yeah before i like knew
what was going on
yeah by the way like a medical
professional took my phone for me
because i couldn't stop texting doctors
for painkillers
so i physically couldn't actually yes i
wanted no you texted me for painkillers
you mustered up the courage i found my
no people were like taking my devices
from me like that's
because i was just like oh the first
week i figured it was just christmas and
stuff and i
listen i like to give you space we've
been we haven't been close for that long
but i also like
you're busy i don't want to it's fine i
got stuff to do so i was giving you
space but then i was like i think she
has fucking covered just want us to know
which also makes sense because you don't
want it to come out before you are ready
to talk about it yeah
you know but i think that people are
going to come after you no matter what
yeah we're just going to come after you
i'm not really worried about
the people coming after me you know you
just want to make sure it's like you're
yeah i just i just really want to make
sure i was able to delineate what was
covid
what was you know just from the
malnutrition and the dehydration what
was from like
the which by the way can we talk about
the uti for a second when you
talk to i just feel like there's still
when you have a uti a random woman knows
more than a male
doctor like i asked three
male doctors and they're like drink
cranberry juice and then i'm actually i
know you cannot diagnose me with juice
i know i can't i'm like one of my four
yeah like when you
go to a male doctor you they're like
just drink some cream grand juice and
some graham crackers i'm like
can i get an antibiotic please the one i
use is called urabel
have you heard of this no my friend alex
from urabel
um my girlfriends were telling me what
antibiotic to ask my doctor for
urabel is a miracle for utis
uh and and it's a prescribed drug and
yes and then
and then i go to the doctor and they're
like and then there's something called
azo azo
and they're like uh yeah you take this
it makes your
p orange and your tears orange i didn't
hear that
and i was sobbing crying one day and i
was just like had orange on my shirt i
liked
fully thought i was like did i get like
a self tan like i didn't know what was
happening because my young lover eating
cheetos
why is it not a product go back to one
if your
tears are orange from taking that it's
not a product that's ready for mars
because it clashes with your hair it's
not ready
it's not ready for market like all these
uti medications aren't ready
like that's if i've learned anything but
i was like on i was just like texting
women
uh and they were giving me better better
medical care than most doctors
were you like annie doesn't have health
insurance i'm not gonna text her did i
not ask you for your help
no you no you asked me for drugs i like
that that's where you go with me
you're like she'll know how to get me i
texted you and i was like can you get me
some painkillers well i checked on you i
said how's my queen
i knew you had covered but i didn't want
to say i know and then you announced it
on this where's the burgess that bitch
oh god so there was a zoom
the beloved uh jeff scott rest in peace
the beloved
piano player for the comedy store uh uh
passed away
uh while i had coved um and i was
it was the day that i had gone to the
doctor and gotten uh anesthesia via an
iv
so i couldn't puke it up so i was like
truly hot i was so fucked up
i i have not been that i was so fucked
up i was wearing a
silk robe uh a floral silk robe i don't
even know where i
got it like it was a zoom memorial so it
was like at the comedy store so
it was like staff it was open micros it
was like
how many people were on this call 100
oh my god i got on a call fully on
i was on like fentanyl
i was so fucked up i got home i was like
smoking vapes
like someone that i love very deeply had
passed away
and i got on the zoom and i just fully
embarrassed myself but that's where i
found jacob
what said she was like i have covered
whatever so i announced it on the zoom
okay so you're sort of getting ahead of
it oh god damn it
it was funny though we're comedians we
all get it god damn it
you may have an intervention coming i do
feel like you're thriving in this
pandemic you're starting podcasts you're
building your business you've got your
mask business like i feel like you're
one of the few comedians that has
really like you know made this work well
i have a kris jenner now
like no i you know i've been really it's
been i just had didn't realize how much
panic i was having during the
regular world i was just panicking all
day and just panicking and stress and
panic and then
when stand-up was taken away and normal
life was taken away i was like what
should i do
and it took me a while but now i had
already started my podcast but now i
have my podcast inspiration on youtube
and itunes
that i actually i was going to tell you
i used it on my last episode i
was i'd say too many filler words so i
was going to use a shot collar
and todd was going to shock me every
time i said like but have you
ever done a shock we were about to do
that um every time i interrupt a guest
you were gonna get shocked yes it's so
painful whitney what i beat you to it
but it's so painful the only way i can
come it's it's
it's no one can ever use it on a dog you
cannot use it yes you can that's not
true
you can but you can um turn it up now
okay no try it
try it at one what store did you buy at
the pleasure chest or did you buy
this amazon listen i got it at amazon
where's the shot caller from
amazon well okay it was it's so painful
i mean todd was like fucking with it and
then set it off before i knew it was
gonna and so i'm just like in the middle
like
i'm like crying i'm like this is so bad
i'm gonna do it again though
i'm sticking with this so me inspiration
and what that means what's that pod like
what is it because everyone's starting
podcasts now you have two
you have one successful podcast and
another one like what advice would you
give to people that are like starting
podcasts right now
um i mean what's working what's not
working i'm still trying to figure it
out i don't know like should i have
segments
it's like kind of right now it's like a
slice of life kind of like what happened
this week which is hard because you're
not going anywhere but yeah
um and just like things i saw you know
and just ideas and
i just rewatch them and i come up with
ideas for the next one
and i would just say if you have a
podcast just watch it and edit it just
watch it and go through it trim the fat
yeah trim the fat and it might not
you're not as interesting as you think
but also just
watch your own shit yeah don't have
don't try to give it to someone
but it's easy and it's because if you
don't like it and then you're putting it
out there and like how are they supposed
to like it that's how it was with stand
up
i remember my ex-boyfriend saying that
to me i was like i can't listen to my
studios if you can't listen to your set
you're a fucking monster for doing it in
front of other people
like how dare you like nation
and and the truth is that when i watch
it sometimes i fucking laugh so hard i'm
like i'm cracking myself up it's so
embarrassing
and then you start masturbating and
that's crazy but um
yeah and so i'm trying to make the solo
thing happen because that was more of an
interview thing but i
don't have people over my apartment yeah
i it is weird it's like
you have this talent of being able to
share without destroying yourselves and
i think that's
that's like the skill we need to learn
now as comedians is like how much can we
share without
over sharing to the point of hurting
ourselves yeah i mean and i think it's a
lot you learn each time because there's
sometimes i say stuff and then i leave
and i'm
i'm like why did i tell that yeah
fucking story but i feel like a podcast
i like
for me like i want to leave it all on
the table like i just think that's what
we're doing like
every time i leave podcast i'm like i
shouldn't have said that like every good
howard
howard interview i've ever done i've
left being like i shouldn't have said
what howard dean howard stern
uh like i think if i haven't left a
podcast feeling like embarrassed i
shouldn't have said that i probably
didn't do a good job
yeah you know me every time i do a
podcast i leave and i'm like totally
like that wasn't funny that was a
nightmare
that sucked well it's also just one
podcast that's what i was it's like
there's just one thing
and you just keep going and keep doing
it and
yeah and you know don't i'm still
learning this sort of
space yeah but also it's like you get a
free it's better to
over speak or over share and then you
can correct it on the next podcast
well you know i feel a little bit rather
than censor yourself nobody wants
careful comedy that's boring
i can be canceled at any moment it's all
out there my roasts everything there's
no we have no con
it's just like detaching from the
outcome of everything and just
i think that i'm funniest when i'm like
tethered so i'm not gonna start all of a
sudden yeah comedians we're supposed to
be dangerous we're supposed to say shit
that upsets you that's like literally
our job description
and when she drives you you do really
she's very dangerous
almost died um i love you so much
what else do we need to cover follow
follow the uh
follow me on instagram andy letterman
because we're a real professional show
we have a doctor coming on
to ask kobe questions too yeah see if
and when he's gonna go are we friends
are we enemies do you think i'm pretty
um annie do you want to um since you're
the queen of all podcasts do you want to
um
intro our uh dr boris wiseman
i mean one word she slurs is the last
name of the fucking doctor i have to
intro
uh uh dr boris weissman wiseman on the
podcast
okay guys um this this next
guest is you may know him from
diagnosing
whitney cummings with kovid from and not
giving me the painkillers i asked
from being begged for extra painkillers
drawing hard boundaries and sticking to
them
yes not being manipulated the one person
not being manipulated by the queen
this is someone that money can't buy
yeah someone money can't buy
when you asked me for pills i was like
what can i borrow some money to get find
these i don't know what you
need for me um i was in so much pain i
was literally just texting people
like how i thought it was easy to get
painkillers in america turns out it's
not
you gotta go to mexico anyway uh
so the great the safe
dr boris there's a real doctor here that
went to a real medical school with a
real degree
answering your questions here he is dr
boris westminster boris weissmann
we're back on good for you with a real
live
doctor it's me
we have a real live doctor and uh
a female comic who occasionally dresses
as a sexy nurse
for her young boyfriend i'm the opposite
of a doctor
i'm the sick patient so dr weissman
you are who diagnosed me with kovid yes
how was that experience for you you
lucky dog
you were a lot less funny
when i diagnosed you than i had imagined
so you're in a mask right now is what
we're doing safe right now
in your opinion clearly not because
you're in a mask
i mean i think it's my it's part of my
duty to to
set a good example wear a mask anywhere
that i go
i have been vaccinated i've gotten both
of my vaccines
you know i imagine that i'm i'm in a
pretty safe space but i wear a mask
around everyone i don't trust anybody
you think we're so filthy we could get
through the vaccine with our germs
well he would be able to give it if you
get the vaccine you can still carry it
to us
right or is that vaccine is not a
hundred percent effective
so when they say like 95 you know
effective that
that other five percent those people can
contract covid
in the right situations and if you can
contract it you can spread it
can we just ask you some rapid fire
questions because i feel like everything
i knew to be true about kova three
months ago has all been debunked and i'm
basically all right now
yeah can you just help me most of what i
do every day work for the last nine
months has been
a good question and i basically get my
news and
health advice from comedians so i'd like
to just start getting it from doctors if
that's okay
same can does the sun still kill it
outside
yeah i mean being out in the s being out
in the sun if if things are laid out in
the sun like you get a package or
something and you leave it out there for
long enough uh-huh
yeah the ultraviolet rays will kill it
long enough as in
20 minutes two hours depends a little
bit about on what kind of surface
okay oh but um i think for the most part
we got away from what we were doing back
in march and april which is wiping
everything down
that comes into the house right most of
the time i think we came to realize that
unless you're
you know your postmates guy just coughed
or sneezed on your package
right pretty difficult to get it that
way got it the main way of transmission
is
i breathe on you you breathe on me right
no kissing
hold your breath i'm hearing is this a
rumor i heard it was anal
well how do you think i got it um uh
are people getting it through their
eyeballs that
also i mean i usually when i test people
and when i'm going around to hospitals
and
seeing patients that potentially have
covet i will wear goggles or face masks
so it needs an entry point you know
mouth nose
in theory eyes you mean like swim
goggles like you go in with like or you
mean this i really mean like
kareem abdul-jabbar sort of you know
i've been so stoned on edibles last
couple months my eyes have been very
closed
so i don't think they got through my
eyes my eyes haven't been opened in four
months so
but i don't think that's a major source
of transition if you're wearing a mask
yeah wearing the uh because uh
a lot of people are wearing the mask and
then i've got a what is it a face shield
on top of it
listen i mean how careful you are
depends a little bit of what are you
trying to do
where are you going are you outside
seeing people
you know in my case i might be seeing
someone who's actively sick
yeah coughing sneezing whatever i'm
gonna
we hang out with comedians so we're
around way more sick people everyone's
always coughing and disgusting
around comedians i might do like you
know full space suit
yeah oh but then you'd get roasted what
is this new strand
talk i just don't trust the news anymore
i don't trust anything because it's like
it'll be like
new strand people and then you go to and
it's like when you actually read the
article
it you see that the um headline was like
total click bait so it's like a dot biz
of viruses going around all the time
that are sort of these slight tweaks to
them
for the most part the ones that we worry
about that are ones that
make it easier for you to catch right
i'm convinced i got the new strain
am i wrong i'm convinced i'm currently
getting the newspaper i'm
pretty sure this is my academy and
i'm gonna be one of the young ish ones
that gets it i don't know that it
changes a lot for us
in the sense that you still have to
protect yourself you're still sort of
waiting to get vaccinated
um in the fact as long as the vaccine
works against the new strains
i think our strategies are pretty much
the same so the vaccine that you did the
current vaccine
will also work against possible new
strains that's that's what the data
shows so far
like everything else in this yeah now
just wait three months we'll see if that
changes
so that's the big thing is we just kind
of know what we know and then we just
have to
expect it to be debunked in three months
well i don't think that's necessarily
like a bad thing
i know when something's new
is not to get sort of stuck in your
dogma of this is how it is
we've learned you know better what
medications work what doesn't work
what does work intubating everybody in
the hospital
you know putting you on a breathing
machine as soon as you came in basically
and it turned out that they learned that
that really wasn't the way to go
wow yeah that was awesome and you sort
of felt they we found some medications
that were
what works some different techniques
there's some steroids are a big one
like some ethanol that they use you gave
me steroids right you've got some
steroids at some point
your neck does look a little
[Laughter]
oh my god your okay you're crazy you
just got so many cuts so i know i can't
show my hands anymore it's just like too
triggering to people
um uh so steroids like chloroquinine
that ship has sailed right yeah
clorox bleach not helpful yeah if you
drink it it will definitely kill the
virus
[Laughter]
but yeah i wouldn't go that way because
what did you give me you gave me an
antibiotic right away
i mean there was a couple of other
things possibly going on with you
because god hates me she just wants you
to dye your hair brown
everyone's just like what can we do to
make this bitch put her hair back
be a regular person again do you think
my immune system has been suppressed by
the amount of clorox bleach i put on my
head every two weeks
i haven't even thought
i know for the most part for people that
are not hospitalized there's not a whole
lot to do
i mean most of the stuff is just trying
to make you feel better taking tylenol
for aches and pains
that did not work for me and fevers yeah
i don't think tylenol yeah how
annoying is that you're like dying and
someone's like take time out but i
literally
like whenever i had it because i was
like drink water like go fuck yourself
fucking migraine no but i uh i was
trying to take painkillers and i
couldn't keep them down is that a common
experience
what's made this interesting and what ma
makes all these conspiracy theories
you know keep blowing up is because
there are some people that
get barely anything yeah and other
people are going to the hospital being
miserable for a week
you know hallucinating like in your case
i mean you were out there
i was hallucinating so bad that i i
thought the guy that um my lover who was
taking care of me
i was calling my friend nick and i was
like he's not giving me the meds
like i was packing i had a bag packed of
like loafers and like three sweaters
and i was gonna leave in the middle of
the night like it was why
i went batty and then i was like
hallucinating um
and then i turn on the tv and there's
like people in raccoon
hats storming the white house and i'm
like this is bad
like the news made it so much worse
because
everything that was happening in reality
was so much worse than my hallucinations
that like it's just the confluence of
how insane uh reality is right now with
my hallucinations
was just making it worse yeah i feel
like when people call me now with like
hey i'm having this symptom could it be
covered the answer is always yes right
that might be right what about this
that's that could be covered too
i got very paranoid i i also like now
in the aftermath like i'm having like
mine was more neurological
and muscular than respiratory i didn't
have any respiratory stuff right you
were breathing okay
yeah strong lungs i don't know what that
was
so very achy though but people are
having neurological stuff that's what
that's what's freaking me out
well you were texting me like at random
you're like i'm in so much pain i'm like
because of the dog
like she didn't you didn't i didn't tell
you i had kovacs i'm like what these
dogs really got in there and i'm like
ask the fucking guy i fully asked annie
for painkillers and i'm like i was
giving her my friend who's a nurse's
number i was like do you want to hit her
up she can come to your house she's like
she's like doctors aren't going to give
me drugs because they don't want to kill
a celebrity i'm like you want me to go
into the street and get you street drugs
but i got i was like doctors won't give
me drugs because they're worried they're
going to kill me like michael jackson
like michael jackson ruined it for the
rest of us like i'm going to take him
responsibly
this bitch wants me to go like find a
drug dealer on the street like go to a
fucking homeless encampment
i can take percocet like a lady like
just i can do that so i was trying to
like convince all the doctors that
and then what else um uh was i i was on
percocet oh and then i started ordering
weed edibles on that little like app
or whatever and that didn't go great
this is exactly what we recommend for
treatment
is this like you're living right there
as a doctor hey uh did you get your
illicit percocet edibles
but our is our because i that's where
the conspiracy theory came in for me
because i was like painkillers don't
work on this that's the one thing
america has
is painkillers that's the one thing
we're great at
and those aren't even working no you had
you've had some earlier conspiracy
theories
in our chat with joe you were like
texting once
wait i just realized that the guns we're
using to
take our temperature are from china and
by the way
the finger the little finger oxygen
thing i was like is it a coincidence
that everything i'm ordering is from
china was like
uh you know everything's from china you
know that right yeah even though rogan
was like you've got a little off the
grid
you're listen i have alex jones over
here making more sense you're gonna need
to
i mean i was going to some wild places
but it's also the kind of sick that you
is this everyone's experience it's the
kind of sick that done you know
the flu or the cult like you can kind of
like watch tv and watch the crowd
like this was like you had to be on
alert all the time
and you're just i was just sitting there
like you're gonna get through this
you're gonna get through this like
i couldn't sleep it makes you kind of
manic people that get sick are getting
really sick different sick not just
feeling like oh this is just a little
something the people that are affected
that come through it that had it for you
know legitimately a week
or more we'll all tell the same story of
that was bad that was miserable and then
also i
i also want to make sure i'm not you
know exaggerating or minimizing you know
annie and i were talking about this last
night like
i'm trying to figure out also
delineating what
is from just the straight-up dehydration
and like i wasn't able to keep food down
i wasn't able to drink a lot so it's
like of course i'm gonna have a headache
i haven't eaten in three weeks so like
what's from the covid and what's from
just the
that aftermath everybody that watches
and listens to this podcast knows that
whitney has sounded like she's been
underwater for like four months
i guess that's the most because i wasn't
i have to i was not taking care of
myself i think i was in this place where
i was like
i was i had a sinus infection but i was
so excited to not have kovid that any
other ailments i was like okay it's just
a sinus infection as long as i don't
have cova like i think we're forgetting
about all the other
things that happened to us as well
i'm definitely seeing fewer people come
in for all their regular stuff yeah
because high blood pressure
diabetes they're afraid of us wow nobody
wants to go there yeah there aren't
more people dying of heart attacks
because they just don't want to go to
the hospital that's right
afraid to see us i mean we're lucky my
office we have like a little courtyard
outside
so i've had to tell a few people like
listen i mean
there is no way that i can look in your
ears or listen to your heart over the
phone
it's just impossible so you can come you
can stay outside i'll see you outside
but sometimes you just need to you just
need to see them you listen to people's
hearts i never even thought about that
that's so sweet
oh i want to let you know he's you can't
say this but he has like
a belt of of hand sanitizer
yes ready to go so do i also how what
are the chances i'm getting
covered right right now we all tested
before this what are the chances that
right now
one of us has it and is spreading it if
we all tested
because slightly different circumstances
you've had it recently
recovered vaccinated i don't know what
the situation is for
the crew around but um have orgies
publicly all the time
all naked by the way yeah well we were
afraid that it would stick to their
clothes so yeah whitney made them strip
down and we are going to start doing
plexiglas
between them and the guests and stuff
like that yeah after annie yeah i mean
i don't have followers to get the
plexiglass okay
i need a sponsor for that um like
i've heard it described as like all
these uh measures that we take is kind
of like swiss
cheese like any of the measures is
imperfect like one slice of swiss cheese
you can sort of punch a hole through it
virus can get through it you start
stacking different measures on top of
each other
you know tested tested once tested twice
some distance mass things like that and
you start to
make it much much harder for the virus
to get and we have to we have to get to
a place where we can function i mean
marvel movies are shooting i'm shooting
a tv show
like if they shut down because someone
gets covered great but like we a lot of
people are figuring out a way to
function and shoot movies you know and
i'm
and the way they're shooting is they're
taking these tests that are imperfect
yeah but they're doing them often right
doing them every day every other day
something like that right and they're
breaking up people into pods and that's
how
movie productions are going right why is
la
so bad is it because of apartment living
intergenerational living like what
why is this so deeply embarrassing
i mean this is a nightmare la's
embarrassing for a lot of reasons
but it's also so cute it's all guys stop
talking
about everything um but yeah it's still
80 degrees today in l.a why are my
friends in texas doing show
like what's happening why is l.a like so
embarrassing will they be back
in texas too yeah a lot of places are
bad we test a lot more in la than in
other places hospitals are full in other
places too
but yeah we're bad here because we're
we're tucked in together
apartment living um we're working
there's lots of generations especially
you know
not everyone has a huge house right i
know i am feeling attacked with this
apartment living
yeah by the way it's cute that you think
you're gonna get it from here
and not your elevator button and laundry
machine but okay do you think i have an
elevator in my apartment
in a laundry machine oh my god her
doorman
[Laughter]
um so la just is just
give cosmopolitan cities are just going
to be worse number one because more
people are getting tested so there's
going to be more proof that they got it
other cities they might just have it we
just don't know places where we're
tied in together i mean new york was
sort of the the poster child in the
beginning everyone was
is really packed in there they had it
the worst
yeah but i think what you'll see is you
know after you recover you have
some level of immunity we're not exactly
sure how much and for how long
so all these flare-ups you see this dip
afterwards so in new york the numbers
got
after it was terrible it was actually
really good for a while right
everyone had it everyone got the crap
scared out of them yeah how many people
are getting it again because i know a
couple people that got it
still relatively rare to get it a second
time and
the the second round for people that do
get it it's much more mild yeah
is six feet still uh the distance that
makes sense i'm mostly asking because
i'm
selling a lot of merch
[Laughter]
moving a lot of units here i want to
make sure my merch is accurate
yeah i know six feet is still is still
the recommendation yeah
okay thank you so much thank you two
inches away thank you so much
it's great it's good six feet is still
perfect um
uh you know and it seems like uh
the best way to move forward is uh to
take care of our immune systems and
like zinc i'm hearing a lot about taking
zinc in the morning what
for just the average person would you
recommend
i think it is one of the most
underappreciated undertalked about
things in this pandemic is
well people with good immune systems
tend to do better so
out of shape fat america it's not so
surprising
that we didn't do so well i mean we
should be trying to keep better
you know keep ourselves in better shape
exercise
drink more water there is some thought
that you know taking zinc
uh and zinc lozenges at least for a
while we're still
we're still treating coveted patients
with zinc in the hospital
um like a zinc lozenge every morning
yeah not a bad thing
but in general just getting healthy yeah
you know stop smoking yeah stop oh i
started
i know i didn't i only smoked one pack
we land on vapor
yeah this is so fun you know slimming
down
i mean we see we know that people with
all those co-morbid conditions of like
the diabetes and the obesity
high blood pressure getting it worse so
what can we do to get rid of those
things
we can be less american right right
right well that's all still true
yeah yeah because it's like i mean in
sweden like and and do you just
do you um i mean not only they probably
have
better leadership but but is the reason
a lot of the scandinavian countries
don't have it as bad because they're
just healthier in general
yeah countries are doing better that are
healthier in general easier to start
better medical systems easier to i mean
this
this whole process you know that here
there was a a portion of who do you know
do you know someone that can test you
do you know how to sign up for the
vaccine here there's an
aspect of that couldn't tell you this is
really weird yeah
it's weird that we don't know it's weird
that i don't know where to get my news
it's i'm literally
getting it from hearsay from like random
friends or like down at the forum
getting the vaccine i'm like i didn't
know it was available
and also like i'm um uh dating a medical
professional
um but he's a veterinarian and they
qualified but they didn't even know that
they qualified
you know they were getting our news that
way
yeah there's no like central piece of
information
and that florida started doing seniors
but
california wasn't doing vaccinating
seniors new jersey's
vaccinating smokers that's my favorite
thing is that
jersey yes it's so jersey what do you
have to
do to prove that you're a smoker picture
smoking i'm like
i'm like where's the photographer you
have to just show up like hey i'm here
for a minute
in my mouth i just need to see your
crow's feet on your lips
like i just need to see your nail to
make sure it's yellow
that's wild i had no idea about that
yeah watch it's not true but i think it
is
i don't fucking know well fact check it
we'll fact check it so rogan said it's
true
yeah no i told joe and he ignored it so
it must not be
something that strikes us he muted our
chain a while ago
um what the question i had is the
does blood type come into play i know
i've heard rumors yeah there was
by the way anything in the news i just
call a rumor now i read that on the news
and i'm like i'm hearing some gossip
that's how little i trust the news at
this point yeah um
no there seems to be some difference
between blood type but i think because
you can't change your blood type
there's certain blood types that make it
seems to be
a little bit easier for you to get
covered and one that makes it a little
bit
less easy for you to get covered and
it's fucking a is the bad one right
well since you fucking want to since you
can't change your blood type we're not
talking bra size we're talking about
danny don't get confused danny i don't
have a negative
um i have a.a meeting i should probably
be at um
like you know we're trying to book shows
we're trying to get back to doing
stand-up
um when is it like
the fall like what are we look in terms
of when are you gonna
go into a building with a hundred other
people and watch comedy
this doesn't count
uh you know i think at least
things are starting to turn the corner
okay just now i mean
the local hospitals in la have
the hospitalization rates have dropped
about ten percent so that's something
like
we're not for a while every day the news
was just
record number of people even more people
now we're doing you know
icus on the roof and in the parking lot
to be fair though
like should our healthcare system have
been more prepared for something like
this
because like our we're slammed but like
were you ever
equipped for something like this in the
first place i mean hospitals
i don't yeah i don't think we're
i don't think we're legitimately ready
especially on the leadership side of
what are you going to do
because you can't just create nurses you
can't just snap your finger
and there's another nurse that can take
care of you in the icu you can make more
you know respirators and things like
that but
i don't think we have that capacity when
they were talking about
in new york graduating medical students
early i mean
i didn't i didn't know anything on the
first day that i graduated medical
school
there would be any help to anybody i
might be able to like write somebody
write somebody's name down i think i
could go from
my first day of medicine to
i am going to help intensive care unit
patients
no but i i think there has to be a way
to find
you know to get sort of more medical
professionals in the loop
um whether that's a national guard or
whatever those sort of people but there
has to be a way to get where are these
people
in the offices they're on bumble
cena you bumble all cops what the hell
is it all it's not it's the craziest
thing i've ever seen anyway
i don't know you've had a boyfriend for
two years working on bumble
todd i hope you're listening to this oh
he's my living assistant
11 years younger no big deal can we just
talk about like i mean my experience
with this like i've been through a lot
of pa i've
i've had pain i broke my shoulder like i
have a pretty high tolerance for pain
like
this to me was such a like mind fuck and
it just made me realize like just the
mental health crisis of this like just
like being alone being unable to
communicate like
i couldn't even like facetime my friends
i couldn't connect with people
like it's what's gonna happen to our
mental health
and what can we do what i'm just
laughing about how you got
covered and then broke your face and
then got attacked by dog
i mean nothing funnier than i haven't
talked to for three days like
to every day talking no talking then
it's just hospital
pictures blood everywhere i'm like holy
shit
i will say covet impaired my judgment i
think it's safe to say
and my taste in clothes uh i have been
dressing like um
an osh gosh my gosh model since i had
covered i've just had covered since the
beginning of the panda
but there have been some weird shit like
i don't know if it's just because i was
like off the grid for three weeks but
like little things like i was eating
toast the other day and i was just
eating it like it had almond butter on
it and i was just eating it upside down
and my dude was like toast goes that way
and i was like oh right like it's just
like
weird little i don't know if that's a
common covet symbol
i know well that's the other thing is
everyone i was like driving with um with
grace and i was
i was just like i hadn't driven in a
while and i was like having spatial
issues and i was just like
forgetting where i was going like i just
felt like i had like brain fog
and um and bent was like well you always
drive like that like i mean it is hard
when you jump into the comedy store i
was like that's a green light i'm kind
of trying to blame a lot of uh
my flaws on code and it's not going over
well no one's buying it
i do think that underappreciated people
that have not had covid
i think the two things that we've seen a
lot of since march has been
a covid b depression anxiety
all the isolation stuff which also
probably weakens your immune system
right that
doesn't help but all the older people
that they really have kept to themselves
not gone anywhere not seen anybody
nobody wants to see them they're afraid
to get them sick
masks i'm just gonna get granular does
two cloth masks
equal one n95 should we just be wearing
95s
can you get your hands on n95s i mean
can you what the fuck dude
yeah i've got one right i've got one
right here and you know it's mine
because the inside is
full of makeup 100 percent mine no
mine's even dirtier than your god you're
saying the old lady thing yes i keep
losing my mass so i
um this company pretty connected makes a
little necklace so you can have it on
because i'll put on other people's masks
why do they know your style too they
just made the brightest color
um no because i and i also was wearing
the cloth masks and when i had a sinus
infection the ent was like you wash your
your cloth mask right i was like i just
put in my purse throw it on i was
watching it like once a week he's like
your mask is like underwear you have to
watch it every day and i was like oh
that is so gross it didn't even occur to
me you have to wash your underwear every
day yeah yeah
you just turn
i mean how can this be less disgusting
than the
cova virus look at all this makeup i
thought you weren't wearing makeup
yeah thank you so much um i'll hit your
mouth i mean i i usually wear an n95
everywhere
the big thing about difference between a
kn 95 and an n95
is an n95 it is like sucked
to your face you have these elastic
straps behind your head
and it's got the um the little metal
thing on the top i mean
i was watching the inauguration the
other day there was someone he was like
anyway
and it was like how do these guys know i
don't know oh my god obama's kept
falling down they're all hugging i was
like oh my god you guys
why can't people get masks that fit it's
wild no they
the winnie comes.com slash merch
they fit they're very snug they're
frankly too small
they're like they're terrible don't buy
it yeah they don't even cover any of
your holes but
um but so like is there anything that
we're like
missing like what's the biggest but wait
are the k95s
the can 95s are great okay they're very
good i got these on amazon
it's not like that airtight seal that
you get with an n95 but the material's
the same
how many times can you wear this how
many times can you wear a disposable
mask
i mean you don't want to wear it forever
yeah and you want to
they say though if you take it out and
you put in like a little brown baggie so
it doesn't
you don't want it to mold oh you're
still breathing and you see all the crap
that's on the inside of it yeah i don't
wear them forever mouths are so gross
do you foresee us just wearing masks
forever in general i
foresee us being a little bit more like
asia going forward that even when this
is all gone
you know if you're getting on a subway
or like you know you'll have people
wearing masks
i owe an apology to all the asian people
in the airplanes that i was judging so
hard i'm like oh my god you guys are
awesome you totally got it
we were such filthy pigs what were we
doing all that time but like
when like emotionally like i'm just kind
of fascinated by the
the the emotional ptsd
the muscle memory of this one i mean
there was a day where we would
go go into a comedy club sit down in the
dark a waitress would hand us a glass
with a straw we would just put in our
mouth in the dark will that ever happen
again
yeah i mean i i mean it's probably
happening right now but if
even if we snapped our fingers and
covered was gone tomorrow would we be
ready to
go to a concert some of us are
emotionally like psychologically exactly
would we
my family's really into sports we're big
dodger fans dodgers went to the world
series this year and we were at home on
our couch
yeah um but would we have gone
if if all of a sudden for the last day
they let 50 000 people back into dodger
stadium
i don't think people would be ready
yeah i don't know i mean there's so many
places like in texas they're like pretty
open
and um but they could be getting it
they're just not getting tested so we
just don't know and they could be
asymptomatic
i mean the other thing i i keep on
having this
this like daydream of what it's gonna be
like
at that first concert where
you actually are not nervous nobody's
nervous like the energy
of a real crowd that first time back i
think will be awesome it's one of the
things
yeah i mean i was doing shows last year
outside and it was just like
the most amazing electric i think if
you're doing it safely it's just like
there's nothing better
yeah definitely feel this bottled up
like people want
to be able to do those things again
can't wait
i just feel like i can't imagine full
capacity for a long time though
yeah it's just wild like are we gonna
live in if we do theaters again are
there gonna be
pieces of glass between us are you gonna
have to walk through like a what
is now would be like a metal detector or
do temperature checks like
the temperature checks are not that's
not really much of anything right it's
not much of it it doesn't
by the time you have a temp of 102 i
would hope that you're not outside
right you know going to see a movie but
you can have it and not have a
temperature
absolutely or spread it not have a
temperature so that's sort of like a
yeah i was like hey something kind of a
fake thing like a false if you're super
sick we'll catch you
right right right right it's kind of a
false sense of security didn't they
arrest a girl for
she got a positive kova test and then
tried to fly didn't they arrest
a girl at lax well there was somebody
that died on a plane i don't know if it
was too lax
of covid oh my god yeah they died
and then it came out that they had
tested positive for covet
and got on the plane and and took off i
forget if it was to lax or because how
hard is that if you
if you go visit somewhere which you i
mean people are still doing
and then you get it you're only supposed
to be there for two days you get covered
you're like i don't want to be stuck and
where am i going to go i don't live here
yeah like how many people are not gonna
just go fuck like
you run a car and you drive i guess yeah
but how many people are not gonna be
like maybe they won't notice or whatever
it's just like this moral
i think things start to get back to
normal when the numbers are down yeah
you have a
decent percentage of people vaccinated
whether you walk into a room and you go
okay
if i'm vaccinated and you're vaccinating
your vaccine well what are the chances
then do we need to
we all be wearing masks and things like
that anymore why everybody's
what's the most annoying uh piece of
fake news that you hear
uh that you have to do about on a
regular basis i mean there's all sorts
of crazy stuff
it was made in a lab or whatever like
what's the most annoying truth i don't
care where it's made
yeah you know the er is full the
hospital's full
i don't care if it was made in china or
not yeah it's putin's
baby right it doesn't really matter it's
out it's here
i think especially people that want to
go back to normal want to get things
back to normal
we have a path it sort of sucks but this
is the path right you gotta
stay safe you gotta wear a mask when
you're around people you got to keep
distance you got to do more stuff
outside
and if the vaccine is offered to you go
and get it so uh
fans wrote in some questions and they're
very good what are the risks of getting
coveted on an airplane
less than we thought in the beginning
because i was on an airplane i never
felt safer everyone was so neurotic
everyone was messed up people were
wiping stuff down i felt way safer on a
plane than i did like
i had the opposite feeling i flew and
everyone
was like it's so safe on the plan and
then i realized my fucking bitch friend
was in first class i'm like it's not
doesn't feel safe back here man
with everyone and then they the middle
seats you had to pay extra for so nobody
bought them so it was
empty in the fucking middle and packed
in the back and i'm like you
fuck that's crazy it felt terrible but
that's where you get sick
well delta was doing a thing where it
was only one person in a row or
something
right i think what we found i had no
idea how often the air got circulated in
an airplane before all of this
i thought you're just bottled in and
breathing the same air just farts and
yeah yeah that whole flight
turns out that they recycle the air you
know about every 10 minutes or so
but if you're sitting shoulder to
shoulder with someone that has covid
for you know your eight-hour flight
that's not great
but it turns out that it's on you're
only at risk for those people right in
your immediate vicinity
so i haven't flown during this but
if i were to fly i'd wear the best mask
i could and planned to not take it off
and wash your hands wash your hands uh
when you get there
when you get off the plane and don't
like put on eyeliner and um
cream blush with your fingers yeah as
someone that applies my makeup with my
hands
uh but also it's about how did you get
to the airport i mean is what we found
did you uber with five other people
yeah you wait in a long crowded line at
the sabaro
like you have to keep to yourself in the
airport before you get on the plane too
are the lockdowns overblown florida and
california
uh florida with no masks and a lockdown
and california have the same spikes
okay this person obviously gets their
news from infowars
but uh let's just stay with are the
lockdowns overblown
i think the lockdowns have been well
first of all if you've driven around la
and you think there's really a lockdown
yeah i know when there was a lockdown
i got from the valley to santa monica in
17 minutes yeah
and now there's traffic almost like
there was before that's right
people have had it yeah people have had
it i think people also
realistically they didn't unders didn't
understand and don't understand why some
things were closed and some things are
not closed
outdoor
if you available thought outdoor dining
and
was that bad you wouldn't have seen our
governor
you know dining indoor with his friends
right if it was life or death
right and then everything would be shut
down it wouldn't be like you can go into
stores for some reason right that the
malls would be open but outdoor dining
was closed do you need to get the
vaccine if you've already had it
so it seems like getting the vaccine
will give you more immunity
that lasts longer if you've had it you
have a
level of immunity but because some
people have it
a little and some people have it like
whitney
i'm a very intense person i go bigger i
go home if i was gonna have covert i was
gonna fucking have it i don't half-ass
anything i do
you're gonna see that same variation
with how much immunity you get
so with the vaccine you're going to get
more immunity and probably longer
uh uh is it possible oh is it possible
that your sinus infection issues are
caused by you getting covent tested a
lot
okay this bitch has my number get it out
this bitch knows me a little too well
that kindness issues might be related to
all the construction going going on the
house yeah okay um
i've heard about thc preventing or
fighting the virus any truth to this
we've got to stop with weed you guys
it's embarrassing it's legal you're not
cool
enough it's just like how did my
husband test positive and i test
negative with the exact same symptoms
you smoke
do you have an answer for the thc thing
sorry for the thc i mean
i don't see that thc has made any
difference
but in general if you're having a
respiratory pandemic
probably don't smoke things someone
wrote is god punishing us
um can i get it from kissing my
imaginary girlfriend okay guys let's get
some real questions here
um uh what is the biggest concern in our
current stage
right now at least the problem of the
day is that
you have enough people that want the
vaccine and you don't have enough
vaccine out there
is it true that they're having like
extra that they have to throw out though
too
yeah so with a lot of the vaccines that
you have now especially pfizer once you
crack the dose you've got to use it
so there are people that show up at the
end of the day after the frontline
workers and people over 65 are
vaccinated and smokers in new jersey
smokers after they've hit those people
if they have if people miss their
appointments
and they've opened a vial for you they
have to either use it
or throw it away and i'd rather them
give it to somebody
rather than throw it in the trash but
should everyone la be crowding down
like to go you know what i mean is that
say are they going to be spreading it
waiting for the vaccine
i mean they have them spread out i think
it's more of a testament to
sort of the organization of the united
states
l.a california that people legitimately
if you told them okay it's not your turn
but it will be your turn in four weeks
in six weeks people want to be done with
this that's right
i i think we all feel that like we're
over it yeah
and i just want some kind of leadership
to tell me this is when you're gonna get
it this is just like the wondering and
the constant
tell me when i'm up i'll wait don't tell
me we're on pace for me to get it in 57
weeks
i'll stand in line at the ralphs yeah
this is a good question
why do we all not have self-administered
at-home testing this feels like a
question for elizabeth holmes girl
someone get her out of jail why do we
not have self-administered at-home
testing there are some in the works
but uh part of the reason why those
tests are not as good mm-hmm
and some of the drive-through tests you
do to yourself are not as accurate
is because you're not trained to do it
and one person's deep nasal swab is
a lot deeper than somebody else's oh my
god i got so horny that was so crazy
um oh when or when are you there
when will the vaccine be given to
children it hasn't even been
tested wow in children so of the two
that are approved now one is for
they started studying at 18 and older
the other one's 16 and old they they
haven't
really completed studies in children are
teenagers at risk like of
not in the same way that the rest of us
are that old people are
this has been a weird virus in the sense
that we don't really need to be that
afraid
for the young kids they can spread it
but they can't
they can spread it but when they're
getting it for them for most of them
it's sort of the same sort of risk as a
as a flu or a bad cold it's not
something that you would
change your life if if we were all you
know 16.
so if we all get vaccinated let's say
everyone got vaccinated
or let's say well i'll just be specific
because i'm it is a selfish question if
i got vaccinated
so me and it's got vaccinations stop
pretending you care about anyone else i
know
i just want to see my fucking daddy this
is the best health care you've gotten in
in your whole life so
i just got insurance um once you get the
vaccine can you fly and go see
your elderly relatives or do you still
need to quarantine no i would think if
if everyone in your circle that you're
seeing is vaccinated
for that little bubble yeah because if i
kill my dad i won't
this won't be good
[Laughter]
okay um uh what's the data for vaccines
against
mutated covavirus yeah so that's of the
different strains
the data so far seems to show that it's
it works against the mutated strains
you're going to get more mutations as
time goes on
and who knows maybe you get a different
sort of strain of the vaccine
in 2022 if you need it for now it seems
to work this is a question that i'm i'm
gonna make jokes about even though i
know it's it's serious like
people are asking the long term side
effects of covid like guys
we won't know until we've had it long
term
like people are like i have permanent
neurological damage i have it forever
i'm like it hasn't been forever yet you
don't know that
it's just uncomfortable for human beings
to say we don't know and especially when
a doctor says we don't know which is
their job to you know
we just want an answer even if it's a
lie i think that
there's a lot of things that we don't
know and i think if we were a little bit
more honest early on with like
getting that message out there of this
is what we know
now but it will change i think we'd be
getting a little bit less pushback
right yeah how rough was that just
having no information at all
i mean that was fun i was wild oh you're
gonna die we are
no we are okay i mean throughout this
pandemic just
the different outfits i've had
when i've you know that first
week or so when they said you don't need
to wear it just like
see people the way you've always seen
sick people you know just wash your
hands afterwards
and a month later i had a full spacesuit
which by the way
i basically modified a yellow painter's
suit from home depot because that's all
i could get my hands on like a hazmat
a hazmat suit and you were wearing it
just
around every time i saw people wow cause
i had to test people i didn't you know
you didn't know
did a lot of your colleagues get it you
know
let a lot less than i thought as soon as
we got
the ppe the the real mass especially in
the hospital think
people were fine before that when they
said well we don't really have those
masks you know
you can just go see the patient and
you know sort of do one of these yeah
there's a lot of a lot of nurses in
particular people that were hands on
that were getting covered because you're
spending a lot of time in a room with
someone that's sick
yeah how long am i contagious after
testing positive
but with almost no symptoms i think
there's this thing where i think people
think if they don't have symptoms
they have less of the virus that's not
how it works
right there might be a little bit of
something to that that
if you are very very sick like did i get
a
because mine was so brutal did i get a
bigger viral load
i just want to i just want to say viral
load but did i get a bigger viral like
we just don't know yet or
no it's possible that people it does
look like that the more symptomatic you
are the more virus you are
pushing out into the air and therefore
you're a little bit more contagious
um asymptomatic people you are breathing
out some virus but not as much
but if you test positive even if you
don't have symptoms
you stay quarantined for two weeks and
that's it hmm
um uh and also here's the other thing
that's hard for people to quarantine a
lot of people live with their families a
lot of people live with their
i mean you know that's another problem
right
it's been a big problem you talked about
multi-generational families you know how
do you quarantine when you
share room or share a kitchen share
bathroom with people i know a lot of
people have roommates that are going out
and being irresponsible they're being
it's just like what a nightmare yeah
that's been tough especially
come stay with me uh he's got a lot of
empty
there's no furniture there's nothing in
this house i've bled all over it sounds
inviting
is it true that blood type o is the
least likely to get it
uh so there is
yeah i believe type o it's a little bit
less likely to get it in type a
is a little bit more likely truth be
told i don't know that we've paid a
whole lot of attention to it because
you can't change your blood type and
it's not that much less likely or more
likely that
you know one blood type can just do
anything they want and
wear a mask and you know people are just
looking for a way to be superior
i have type o like everyone's just
looking for a way i know my
for i have one a plus in my life and
it's the bad one it's such a bullshit
it's the only time you've ever gotten an
a in anything and it's gotta be your
blood type
um i'm sorry that uh these are uh the
fans of our show but
is uh kovid transmissible through oral
sex specifically genital to mouth
contact only
it's a good question that is actually
it's a good question that everyone's
afraid to ask the questions i get from
my podcast are like
would you rather fuck your mom or your
dad jesus every time
okay guys i don't know where you kill
your mom whitney
and your dad which one's wearing it at
95.
like i mean yes right because i would
assume if you're having oral sex we've
kissed them at some point
hopefully don't assume
[Laughter]
um but no i i think you need an airway
you need an entry point i don't think
that
qualifies i have not heard of uh
of this is great news for a lot of
people do you know how sad this is
actually i'm just thinking about
for both directions like so if i'm if
you're just doing
my excuse dude he's like i'm sick bitch
but suck my dick anyway
or if the girl has covered the guy's
like i'm fine you're sick suck my dick
anyway
like covet don't come for a couple yeah
guys do not say to your girlfriend i
just listened to whitney's podcast and
dr weissman said you can still suck my
dick even though i'm covered positive
i would think you got to get within six
feet to second stage
[Laughter]
you can get like a pocket pussy does
that count if you put it in your mouth
like on a thing uh is pink eye a side
effect of coven
no you push shit in your eyes
there's talk of you know kobod uh can
cause
eye irritation and maybe come in when it
does come in through the eye that it
gives you some pink eye so you can't eat
ass guys
it's not the same but you can suck down
i'm sorry um this is why doctors don't
come on our show
very often it's the only reason uh
i'm gonna bring someone with information
and someone who has no information but
we'll interrupt
you um okay yes some of these questions
are just so wildly inappropriate i'm
trying to skip
the disgusting ones nothing i haven't
heard of
um i see the pictures people send me
well if what
they're like is this herpes or is it
dickhoven
[Laughter]
that's pretty on point
do you have any more questions annie um
no because we have a real doctor here
where do you get your news
i truly don't know where to get my news
on this yeah that's a good question
there's a lot of medical stuff that we
read
um there's a like a digital journal
called
netscape that we hit up a lot but i
think we're
we're doing what you guys are doing it's
trying to get it from like multiple
sources multiple places
and uh so q anon.org is
not the best source number two
of coven news because i i wake up in the
morning like i really don't even know
where to go
for news at this point because it's just
gotten so
much strength i try to get also not only
news but
numbers from places that are legit i
know like
in la if you're just following how many
people got kovit
that's been tough to follow because in
the beginning they'd open up like a
super site like dodger stadium
and the numbers go up and you know well
that's probably because they tested more
people and then the numbers just dropped
in la
dramatically not so surprisingly they
turned dodger stadium from a testing
site to a vaccine site
and they're testing 30 000 people less a
day
so like to see how bad
uh the pandemic is at least i just look
at hospitalization rates
you can't fake that right you're either
in the hospital or you're not but what
about the argument i know a lot of
people one of the conspiracy theories i
heard was that
doctors are getting paid more or
hospitals are getting paid more if it's
covered than if it's something else and
so then they're saying anything that
anyone comes in with is covered
yeah i mean i've i've heard that so i
fill out death certificates
jesus um you know when people die they
send a certificate
of bubble letters i don't want to see my
handwriting it's definitely not public
letters
um i don't get paid to fill out a death
certificate
you know but it is a little bit to your
judgment what can
he's like i would have killed you you
know is
was it covid was it heart attack was it
something else
um you put down whatever you want to put
down nobody pays me for that
so larry king did he die of covid we
don't know
that's a good question i had i had
someone die when the hot ones die
taken from us too soon one more wife i
don't know
it could have been me no you're too old
um but i had someone that was in the
hospital he had
terrible cancer got hospitalized not for
his cancer but for
because he turned coveted positive went
home
was home for a few weeks kind of you
know like you hear about some other
people and he died
later was that a covid death
i mean i didn't put covet on his death
certificate
but you know getting coveted or getting
anything getting any pneumonia was
probably a push that guy did not need
right any push right yeah pushed him
over the edge
but so there's there is sort of a gray
area but
you can't deny that the hospitals are
full when they're never full yeah
they have people in the parking lot
intense
what is that from it's not because we're
adding a line
to their admission records of what they
have
that sucks so bad to get how did it feel
whitney when you
had coveted and then had injuries that
you had to go to the hospital for was
that like the worst nightmare
uh i hmm
yeah i mean well the first thing was
like is it ethically responsible to go
to a hospital right now like are they
full i mean i went to
see uh ucla once and it was pretty empty
to get my fingers sewn up and then when
i went to cedars it was
like the lobbies were pretty empty and i
was like i don't know if that means
there's no visitors
yeah i didn't yeah exactly it was like
there's no visitors i didn't know if the
rooms were just full and the lobby was
like it was very eerie like i thought i
was gonna go into like a chaotic like
well it feels different in different
places over here in the valley at
cedar's tarzana
where you pull in they have the triage
in the parking lot they have all these
tents so you see it right away you're
like wait
this is where i was parking before in
other places
it's just that all the hospital beds are
full all the rooms are doubled up
yeah well also when i went in to get my
uh fingers sewn up i had to go in and
say
you guys i'm covet positive do you know
what i mean and then all of a sudden
there's
like and this is from before they were
all in like beekeeper outfits like they
went from like hey what's up to like
fully hazmat suits you know because
that's the other thing if you're going
to the doctor for something else right
now you have to
end half cove it you have to tell them
yeah of course obviously so that was
like kind of weird yeah it's and that
that sort of stuff is making things take
a lot longer yeah so that's part of the
reason why the weights are longer
yeah if you walk in and if someone has
coveted or might have covid
you've gotta yeah get your whole getup
on can we get the vaccine while pregnant
uh it hasn't been studied in we just
don't know
why so the only people that we're not
really sure about
at at least that we don't think that
there's any problem with it that doesn't
sound very reassuring to people that are
pregnant
yeah so pregnant young children
hasn't really been studied in in great
numbers in those people so
i think it's a little too early to say a
hundred percent
yeah go for it mm-hmm oh wait can dogs
give it to you
can you get it like can your dog go like
play with someone who has coveted come
to you
kiss your face give you covered yeah
that's a good question i know some
people
uh some some animals have tested
positive like in zoos
which is why are they testing that it's
so fun they're like this elephant has a
positive it's like why were you testing
it
yeah at times when like we're having
trouble getting people tested
why didn't you hear that this is
oh my god like i just when they're like
a poodle
in florida uh has it i'm like you wasted
a test like what are we talking about
you're just mad cause it was a poodle
i know i'm like yeah
um but uh yeah so you can get it from uh
i don't know
what is the surfaces thing now now it's
not surfaces or
it's just not a major player if you take
if you touch anything that has coveted
on it or you cough in the air
and it's in my hands if i touch my face
quickly enough
mouth nose eyes it's possible so for all
you covered chasers just grab that
sneeze and rub it on yourself i love
people that wear gloves
and they think that that it's different
than hands
people will like walk around with their
gloves and touch their faces like no
it's still
like what do you still have to take the
glo you know what i'm saying like people
think gloves means you wash your hands
one thing that this thing has taught us
is how often we touch our face
right once you've got the mask on and
you feel yourself i know i think that's
been the biggest changes we don't
touch our face as much right i want to
ask one thing that's murky since
everybody thinks they're a doctor now
um when we do tests everyone's like well
that's not the test that works or that
test is ineffective everyone thinks
so the best test has has been from the
beginning and still
is the pcr test pcr what does that mean
uh
it goes off to the lab right it it
usually comes back in
in a few days so if your test is coming
back in 10 minutes that's not the pcr
but if you get a pcr test today and
you're waiting three days
you can't go to a party the next day you
have to court you know what i'm saying
because you can get it in between the
time you test and set it off
is just a moment in time yeah right it's
that moment
it's like a pregnancy test you're not
pregnant today
doesn't mean you can't ever get pregnant
well i do not don't look at us
like you guys will never have to take it
do you have one more question can you
get pregnant on your period
is that a safe method of birth control
so does it pull out method where like
we're just totally going
what is this um
i feel clear i mean i feel like this is
going to be an ongoing thing i feel like
in a couple months we'll have you back
and we'll get the new
science and everything we're saying
today will be completely debunked but
just since i had it i just uh i wanted
to um just sort of let everybody know
well you had quite a riot i'm glad you
uh made it through or we're talking on
the other side
that was wild what was the craziest
thing you witnessed me do
i don't even think i'm allowed to say
the great things i saw you do
by the way we uh you sent over someone
to take my blood or something and i hid
from her in the bathroom for like 20
minutes
she really appreciated that my lover had
to like drag me out and because i was
like who's this woman like i was so
paranoid it was hilarious yeah it's some
really vivid hallucinations i was like
calling you from the bathroom like i
need you to send me
like oxycontin we're like uh we already
sent one in
we are not sending more thank you for
not killing me by the way
you're welcome it's bad for business
thank you thank you for drawing a
boundary
i was really mad at you at the time but
i'm really grateful that you didn't give
me all the prescriptions
i have evidence because she said that
you wouldn't give a shit yeah so i
appreciate that
everyone's scared to kill a celebrity
and it was actually just so funny
because i i elevated myself to like
michael jackson level
yeah it was also just like 1pm i hadn't
talked to you in three weeks i was like
um okay i love you guys uh keep sending
in questions we'll start doing this
regularly
um i love you thank you dr weissman
you're rock star uh don't ride elephants
love you guys
[Music]
[Applause]